[Applause]
[Music]
yeah every game
[Applause]
up next he's a Marine Corps combat
veteran he's a father of five he's the
host of seven figure Squad he and his
wife Sheena are the number one earners
in the history of PHP big round Applause
for Matt Sao Paulo
next to the stage he's Miami's most
eligible bachelor he has a podcast
called sauce cast where Finance meets
romance he's the co-host of the pbd
podcast big round of applause right now
for Adam
[Applause]
and last he's a Visionary entrepreneur a
thought leader he loves the country and
he loves balsamic glaze please help me
welcome to the stage your host the one
and only Patrick Ben Davis
[Applause]
[Music]
guys one more time give it up for pbd
everybody can sit down
[Music]
by the time he's done you wish he would
have ran for office this year but he's
Libertarians when I
when I she is the reason
she brought us together what an
incredible special moment that we had
together uh Dave Smith is a comedian
probably one of the uh most powerful
voices on social media today on many
different topics you'll know if you
don't know about him you're gonna learn
about
give it up Dave Smith
[Applause]
grab a seat grab a seat thank you
it's a little chilly in here
to do this okay
how many of you guys watched the podcast
this morning by the way anybody watch
any of this one yeah did you watch the
whole thing you just kind of watch a
clip of it what you watch the whole
thing
parts of it let me just tell you whoever
by the way let me put it to you guys
this way how crazy it was this morning
with our podcast the guests we had on
the podcast today I don't know I don't
know the last time he was trending it's
fair to say 2016. uh an hour after the
podcast he's been trending all day on
Twitter today all day thanks to the
friendly conversation we had on the
podcast today which is fantastic for
those of you that haven't seen it we'll
give you a clip you'll get a good
understanding of it Dave for the
audience that doesn't know you do you
mind taking a minute and just
introducing yourself to everybody we've
got a lot of topics to go through uh
some of you that are here
uh for the first first time we're going
to talk a lot of politics today we're
going to talk some business today we're
going to talk a lot of politics we got
some crazy things that's going on we got
a couple of weird videos to give you uh
we're gonna talk about the movie sound
of Freedom anybody seen the movie sound
of Freedom yes or no record-breaking it
just hit a hundred million dollars by
the way it tops mission impossible so
we'll talk about that uh we'll talk
about a few other things uh Matt's got a
few things to talk about with pay raises
as well as a story that came out from
Insider Americans are moving to Japan
for its safety and affordability I can
totally see Okafor moving to Japan for
safety and totally see that part and
then we got a couple other weird things
going on one of the topics here that uh
Adam was really insisting we have to
talk about it's it's a topic that the
title here will give it away marriage
outdated two out of five adults think
the tradition no longer matters we're
going to see how you feel about it we're
going to see how Adam feels about it
everybody else here is married but maybe
Adam's going to have a different person
let's get married after the show maybe
there's someone in the crowd what we got
I believe in miracles that's a tough one
here but we'll see what happens so
Dave for people that don't know you if
you don't mind taking a moment
introducing yourself uh sure um Dave
Smith I was uh the campaign director for
Anthony Weiner
we didn't quite get him over the hump
but we did what we could
um now I'm I'm Dave I'm a stand-up
comedian and a Libertarian podcast host
and uh talker of [__]
talk her up [__] yeah yes talk or [__]
talker there's no question about it so I
think we just kind of talk about what
happened today and we'll go on to all
the other topics right Rob do you mind
showing a glimpse of what happened today
on the podcast now how many of you know
who Anthony Weiner is Rosanna if you
know Anthony weiners how many guys don't
know who he is raise that if you have no
clue Anthony Weiner is okay how would
you describe who Anthony Weiner is okay
so uh Anthony Weiner was a congressman
uh from my hometown New York City and um
he he's a congressman named weiner
it's not Weiner and he uh nope
unfortunately it's pronounced Weiner and
he accidentally uh tweeted a dick pic
yeah
um now in his defense
these were the early days of Twitter
and we all made mistakes
of course but he was trying to direct
message a dick pic to some chick and he
accidentally just tweeted it
no no this is not the 14 year old that
came later oh my bad he was just trying
to message some chick of age just good
Christian fun
and
so now this is the early days of Twitter
okay so he tweeted it instead of sending
the message immediately realized he
tweeted it and then hit delete and I'm I
guarantee in his mind he went caught it
because he didn't understand how the
internet works so he deleted it but
there were 500 000 screen grabs of this
thing already and so he was forced to
resign in disgrace
for being a congressman named weiner who
tweeted a dick pic by the way can we do
a can we do a poll PVD
Real Talk men right now raise your hand
if you got a picture dick pic in your
phone right now wow and by the way men
men just before you answer disclosure
come on we will be checking phones
we're gonna find out we'll be
confiscating phones by the end of the
show
but by the way what I know you got
something oh come on stop it bro what
mattress asked what what FYI PHP just
some of some of you guys that are here
this is not the typical way we talk
about the connection but get used to
this is the podcast
so but go ahead so what else could you
say about him so aside from that what
happened with Weiner at one point this
guy's about to be a mayor he was number
two in the uh yes campaign for New York
City he made a comeback after having to
resign in disgrace he comes back he's
running for mayor of New York City not a
small job he is in the top of the polls
when yet more dick pics come out
and that's New York City listen we're
we're a harsh but fair people like we
were we were still considering him after
the first dick pic but then the second
dick that we were like dick pick me once
shame on you
the second dick pic we were like that's
too much so you're plummeted in the
polls now Anthony Weiner also was
married uh to Uma uh Uma abedin if I'm
pronouncing your name right who is
Hillary Clinton's right hand can you
show it a picture Rob so they know go
for it she's Hillary Clinton's like
closest advise our highest level
Confidant and there's some speculation
maybe even more
um I don't know about that but uh so
then weiner uh in 2016 another Scandal
comes out where this time I think he had
actually message an underage girl and
this was a whole thing uh one I forget
exactly how it went down but the NYPD
when and uh raided his house They seized
his laptop now they realized that on
this laptop there are a ton of emails
from his wife which also include a whole
bunch of emails from hell Hillary
Clinton and this is actually what
prompted Comey to reopen the Hillary
Clinton investigation just a couple
weeks before the election so this guy in
some ways got Donald Trump elected
president it was certainly one of those
he's an American hero yeah listen the
guy he did the customer service it all
starts
making an omelet without a few dick pics
so having said that this is what
happened on today's podcast a very
friendly conversation we're having and I
uh I simply asked the question it was
not a crazy question it was a simple
question and it led to this so Rob if
you got it if you can show this clip so
we can get a reaction to it and then
we'll go from there
Paula grober Danny casolero can you see
the video or no because I don't see the
video on the cameras just so you know I
don't see myself on the videos here
Ilan if you can put the videos here so
we can see them the way it was this
morning because right now I'm seeing
myself
okay perfect so if now if you want to go
to the uh is this it
this is the one minute clip that's
perfect that's the one I want you to
show go for it oh man Paula grober Danny
not this one no no I want you to go to
the one go and that's value team and go
to my personal account go to my personal
account if you can show the screen with
Twitter if you can just stay here with
me I don't need to see myself there you
go if you go to my personal account and
go a little lower uh that one right
there all the way at the top oh that one
right there make that bigger it's like
59 seconds it's just some people like
you off that's okay go back go for it
play it served in the military and
dragging their name they have a
reputation to ask tough questions and
piss some people like you off
oh trust me we are standing up for the
morning let's see you better get back to
that list because we're going to clear
some people's names today my question
for you is my question for you is how is
it that in the last 50 years
we don't have a single candidate
everybody has their own hey John F K was
a Playboy with Marilyn Monroe Trump
Karen McDougall Stormy Daniels you know
George Bush linked to 911 and weapons of
mass destruction Bill Clinton linked to
Arkansas women all this others everybody
has a reputation how is it
that the reputation that follows them is
people close to them die
why is that a story that people many
people believe in why are the clintons
in their 70s yet if I you don't think I
can make a list of other people who are
70 something years old and say this
person
hold on how come they haven't done that
with bush he's in the same same name I
have no freaking idea what I'm trying to
say but so are you saying so you agree
with what I'm saying that with Reagan so
how come they have a none that would
care what are you making
no what pisses me off and I'm gonna say
this again because you apparently are
not listening to me you read a list of
people off an obscure website that that
that is that of of conspiracy theory
taking a Venn diagram of everyone that
ever worked in the orbit of someone who
served in public life for 50 years and
you listed them including people in the
military including strangers you could
not pull out of and you are implying
that there's something to fear let me
finish my thoughts let me finish my
thoughts please do so because I got
another let me finish my thoughts I'm
here for you you're implying both with
the question and with the website the
website says it explicitly you're
implying it let me finish go ahead
you're implying that something's done
until he's done
go for it you are implying that
something nefarious is a foot both with
the question yeah and with the list
Hillary Clinton she's a big girl I'm a
big boy you're a big boy the people that
you just listed they're all listen to me
no these are obscure people that you
could not pull out a great politician
buddy
you know what you want you are you are
the classic bull you list someone's name
is
gonna somehow clear that person's name
there's anybody at this table that's a
bigger believer I tell you oh yeah you
you just listed some stranger yes
well technically it the the awkwardness
started before the podcast five minutes
before it was very disrespectful when he
showed up yeah intentionally yeah
perhaps and he apologized in the last 10
minutes which was you know respectful
for him to do it yeah he was being a
dick he maybe a dick pic yeah no he
didn't text me anything I didn't get any
text from him afterwards check your
phone Pat no no I'm not going to get
into text from himself but but listen
from from your perspective you were
saying something in the back about him
on how this happened you know you made a
point right now about the fact that uh
you know if it wasn't for him maybe
Trump doesn't become a president and
you're absolutely right indirectly well
look in the thing is like in an election
as close as the 2016 election was any
one major factor you know kind of is the
difference so you know that was
certainly a major factor I just can't
get past look man that this guy was
sexting with a an underage girl totally
humiliated his family publicly and then
the idea that he's just like morally
lecturing you that you had the nerve to
bring up the fact that it like a
ridiculous amount of people very close
to the clintons have died and like but
you're just not allowed to bring you
didn't say the clintons have murdered
these people you went hey what's up with
this and just like the moral like
condescending to you as if this was some
outrageous offense like what we're not
allowed to even think of the possibility
that maybe politicians have people
murdered like now who's being naive okay
you know like that famous line from The
Godfather look these people the clintons
these are people who we all know have
had had people murdered in Mass numbers
we just call that foreign policy we just
call that when they decide we're going
to go on a bombing campaign in Iraq as
Bill Clinton did throughout both of his
uh terms had a massive blockade around
Iraq where the U.N estimated 500 000
children starve to death okay that this
was the un's estimates I'm not sure if
they're right or not but the idea that
people who do that for a living would be
so uncomfortable also off the clock
being like yeah I'm okay with this guy
being killed is not that wild of a jump
to me and if you want to do a deep dive
into it I'm not going to go full Alex
Jones here but there's a lot of very
suspicious deaths around the clintons
and it's totally fair to bring that up
yeah it's it's by the way I will say
have you seen this documentary or no the
documentary called wiener and it's not a
porn I did say it I did I forgot about
it I did it's the documentary of his
comeback when I watch it originally I
thought it starts in a weird way here's
a documentary winner last night I get
home uh Vinnie where's Vinnie Vinnie you
told me to watch if any somewhere around
here yeah he said Pat you may want to
watch his document or I get home at
midnight from here and I sit down and
I'm like I watch half of it I watch the
other half of the morning next thing you
know an hour and a half later I'm
finishing the whole thing it feels like
five minutes what they did during that
campaign with him and his wife everybody
has to watch because the one area you
got to give them credit this guy was an
incredible campaigner and if there's one
quality that he has that's very hard uh
for most people to have and you almost
need this because
obviously you know if you can get away
with you know the texting side set that
texting part aside and you just kind of
flirt and set the under the 18 side he's
a super competitive psychopath
competitor like many of these other guys
but
the guy is Shameless and there was an
element of being Shameless and
Relentless that he was not gonna let the
right after the second story comes out
he says babe there's a scene you guys
will see this right there's like so
you're gonna get in the video or what we
got to make a campaign video it says
a story just came out that you just
texted a 50. do you want to get here in
this video or not we need to make a
campaign video
do you understand what I just said
there's a there's one point if you
remember I actually forgot about this
documentary but I did watch it there's
one point it was one of those amazing
things I've ever seen in a documentary
if you remember right at the end when
the whole thing is just collapsing for
him
everything's going down and is
collapsing in the polls and it's clearly
not happening and the the guy behind the
camera he's in this moment where he's
just so down and the guy behind the
camera actually asks him he goes why are
you letting us do this like why are you
letting us record this moment and he's
just like
I don't know oh we asked them the
question today Adam I think you asked
him the question today what was his
answer to you he says I said have you
seen it says I've never seen the
documentary and it's how come you've
never seen it he says for an opportunity
one day in an interview like this to
tell you I've never seen it yeah so but
why haven't you so why'd you even let P
why'd you do it what was the purpose of
doing it he says I don't know so people
can kind of see what the story was like
behind closed doors you know but when we
asked him the question I said so what do
you think about Hillary Clinton you know
honorable honest people very honorable
very honest great people etc etc this
guy literally sounded like a full-blown
flat carrier and the word that came out
I don't want to speculate anything but
I'll tell you the word that came out of
my mind and this Ward I got to give
credit to this war to I believe Vinnie
if I'm not mistaken
you ever heard what A a dead man
switches
can you pull up the definition of a dead
man's switch a dead man's switch okay
okay pull it up Zoom it in so we can
read this Adam if you can't move your
feet I can't see it
as a switch that is designed to be
activated or deactivated if a human
operator go a little bit to the right
human operator becomes incapisated in
incapacitated incapacitated such as
through death loss or loss of
consciousness or being bodily removed
from control originally applied or
originally applied to switches on a
vehicle so meaning
if
because he knows everything I said
Anthony you know you know
you know you know
there was a moment it's like I'm saying
I know for a fact you know what nobody
here I don't know anything and he's
looking at me like you know how are you
alive
how are you alive the only way you can
be alive is because of this
where they fear if they do something
that maybe like this is going to come
out and something's going to Trigger
story being emailed to everybody in
media and they're going to be like holy
[__] so that is the only way I can in my
mind justify why he's alive why he
builds them up why they protect each
other and why the other people are
sitting there saying let's leave this
guy alone now obviously all of this is
speculation yeah no one knows if there's
credibility behind it or not but it's
worth speculating well I think that like
one of the things that we kind of
learned from the whole Jeffrey Epstein
uh Scandal is that there are at least in
this one major like uh example there are
these attempts to like gather blackmail
on very powerful people and this is part
of the reason why really [__] up
people rise to the top because people
who are say like if you're say texting
with an underage girl and someone has
information about that they now can
control you completely that's what the
whole Jeffrey Epstein thing was
essentially he'd invite these powerful
people out to parties they'd be like
there's parties there's tons of chicks
there'd be there'd be cameras in every
room you go there you hook up with one
of the chicks the next day Jeffrey
Epstein goes by the way she was 15. and
also you're going to be voting no on
this legislation that's coming across
your debts next week like that was
essentially there's there's some
speculation whether he was working for
the CIA or Mossad or who he was working
for exactly but that basically the
operation my guess would be someone like
Anthony Weiner there's people we may
know some of the dirt on him but who
knows how much dirt all of these people
have on him so he may be very required
to when Hillary Clinton comes up you go
to bat defending what a noble person she
is or else you know what's crazy Pat
that that blows my mind that
so many people are oblivious to this how
much back-end crap goes on whether it's
blackmailing each other like for example
you think about like the clintons for
example you're thinking about these
powerful people they've been in power
like to a normal everyday person like
you and me you don't think about killing
somebody because you don't have a lot to
lose you don't have anything to lose you
lose a job you'll get your next one you
know you lose whatever you you know
company fails you're only making two
three hundred thousand dollars a year
you go start another company but when
you're in power for so many years at the
highest level of your life and you're
making this much money and that chair
that you have makes you so much money
you'll do anything to keep it but
everyday people can't think that way
because you don't even imagine of
killing your boss if they fire you
because the reality is what do you have
to lose you don't have a lot to lose but
when you have your entire power to lose
and even the Bible says about that it
corrupts people King David did it that's
why he went to go sleep with the wife of
his General and then wanted to cover up
by killing the putting the General on
the front lines to have them killed
God's men have done this what makes you
think these politicians are not doing
that I mean the Bible tells us it shows
us examples of this so the fact that in
politics when people like you defend
your candidate as if they were never to
do anything wrong because your party's
the one that oh my God it's like bro you
can't you can't imagine what's going on
behind the scenes they have to keep
their power and they will compromise and
they will kill if they have to just like
King David killed in order to keep his
secret the fact that he had impregnated
the wife of one of his generals I gotta
say it's very uh soothing to know you
have no desire to kill your boss like
any guy I
I that's why I don't do well we're
bosses because I don't I I do have those
thoughts so you know
and with my record you know
I come through
Ricky walks in we're having dinner I say
uh uh uh Dave this is uh Matt and Sheena
sapala you know here's who they are this
is what they do here's how there's
Rodolfo and CeCe Vargas they're doing
this they're doing that here's Ricky
just got out of jail just last week and
so very cool good to meet you I don't
know I looked at it checked out to me
the only person everybody you got to
know that the only person here looks
like they're dressed appropriately for
the location in South Florida we got to
give it up Ricky's out there look it up
right there with
sure we're dressed in suits
next story
dated marriage outdated Adam be ready
two in five young adults that picture is
is kind of selling the idea yeah exactly
two in five young adults think the
tradition no longer matters a survey
reveals that two in five young adults
consider marriage an outdated tradition
with a with 85 percent believing that a
fulfilling and committed relationship
doesn't require marriage the sentiment
is more prominent among women 52 percent
wow 41 men the survey reflects a broader
Trend as one in four forty year olds in
the U.S have never married
and 34 of people 15 and older have never
been married 15 and older or 15 year old
never been married the rising cost of
weddings a major deterrent and 73
percent of Millennials Engineers
considering you're too expensive young
adults feel judged for not being married
especially by their mothers 69 of women
27 of men fear of divorce is also
significant factor with 47 expressing
concerns and many couples lack plans for
shared responsibilities like pets and
children in case of a breakup so Adam
why do you what do you think about this
article here well I guess marriage worth
it is it not worth it what are your
thoughts on this I mean let me just say
this I think that at the end of the day
men and women are better together I
think uh we're here with PHP I think uh
you guys how many how many of you guys
are married couples working together
there you go there you go
literally everyone exactly and I'm not
pandering to the audience I genuinely
believe that respect but 90 of hands we
just went up yes well I don't know what
that was
um but you might have saw that I was
trending on uh social media me and my
ex-girlfriend Chelsea Handler had a bad
breakup yeah heartbreaking I remember
thinking about it used up uh 50 year old
lady Vibe and um I think there's two
things going on here I think number one
women
um have been fed a um bowl of lies from
Modern Day feminism uh telling them that
they don't need a man go out work like
make your money
why need a man in your life just do it
by yourself
and I think that's just an absolute
shame because I think that women the
number one role of a woman whether it's
here we go here it is I think and I
asked married women all the time get the
shoes ready lady here we go ladies
I don't care how much money you make
what you do for business the best thing
you've ever done is have children and
raise great children okay I'm looking at
many women right here as amazing as
Sheena Is and as
amazing as Marlene is whoever's out
there your kids are the best are they
not okay you would trade everything
you're doing why they were well yes just
recently you know it's it's been summer
kids been home so I guess my kids are
not good they're not going to school
right now I know parents feel it you
know and I know Matt with your dozen
kids you know what I'm saying about this
brother
and then I think that
um women when they enter this modern day
mindset of feminism
men when they make money they look for
dependents yo I'm a man I made my money
let me go find my girl my family I'm
gonna do my thing a lot of women are
like I'm independent I don't need my man
so it's sort of counterintuitive men are
very fearful these days why because of
the court systems 98 of alimony are men
paying women so 98 not 90 like these are
very high numbers so I do a show called
sauce cast where Finance meets romance
and I have these difficult conversations
about prenups nice little plug there you
like that
um and and
like you just saw
um the soccer player who hid his assets
in his mom's name and the woman divorced
him and basically what happened was she
came after his assets he's like I ain't
got no money baby like I got nothing the
mom had it all and ironically enough she
she's a hot model she makes a million
bucks a year now she's paying him at
alimony Allegiance it's beautiful so I
think yeah
come on guys we only win two percent
the leaders as bulletin says Erica
Juarez so that's why that's beautiful
because if we ever get divorced Eric's
gonna be paying me since I don't have
anything
my flexor is well he just got out of
jail everything's in his mom name you
know that thing works absolutely I think
I think what Society is lacking is
genuine examples of what great
relationships and marriages and families
look like that's why I love pbd and his
family because what an amazing situation
the only other person that I would
constantly look at and be like wow
that's the man is Tom Brady Super Bowl
winning quarterback GQ stud millionaire
this that the other model wife Giselle
hot this family kids and it's like she
leaves Tom Brady and I say this all the
time it's like Giselle I know you're hot
and all but good luck finding another
Tom Brady right so I think Society
what's the Wall Street Journal article
about crumbling values in America today
religion Family Values community service
marriage like I think we're trending the
wrong way and I think that it's
incumbent on men and women to understand
what's happening in society today and
not just like oh Adam you're an [__]
you're a chauvinist no I want to get
married I want to have a family I want
to have kids but I also want to be aware
care of the pitfalls of what's going on
today yeah well it's like reading this
article I mean it's just it's very to me
it's very sad
um number one because it's just like you
said it's it's a clear sign of like
societal Decay that we would even be in
this situation look the objective
reality is that marriage is the best
situation for children and that should
be our priority what's best for the
children and there's something so
perverse about our current culture where
there's so much focus on kind of like
the like you the individual this is one
of the things that drives me crazy about
always celebrating people who come out
as as trans and they're like oh this is
wonderful you're being who you are you
know you were always a woman and you
have to live as you feel and like no one
ever seems to go like hey what about the
kids and what about your business well
yeah that's well you don't turns out you
don't have to do anything to that now
um but it's just like there doesn't seem
to be concern about this and that's that
by the way that's how Society continues
is through children and just to your
point Adam I mean look I would say I
don't think it's just like a thing for
women I mean I like I love my career I
really love it I have my dream job I
love doing stand-up comedy I love doing
cool shows like this I love it I make a
very good living you know not compared
to some people but compared to the
compared to the general population I do
very well and I have a career that I'm
passionate about that I love that's
pretty rare it's a small percentage of
society who has that and still if you
were to ask me what's the most
meaningful or important thing in my life
it's not like career is number two it's
such a distant number too the older you
get the more you realize all that really
matters is family that's all that
matters and I think it's very easy
particularly for women just because they
do have more of a biological clock just
that's the reality than men it's very
diff it's very easy when you're 25 to be
like I don't really care about any of
that I'm having fun I'm doing my thing
and then it's very easy to do that up
until you're 35. and by the time you're
35 you're up against it you are
immediately you're in a high risk
pregnancy if you get
the risks of something going wrong on
top of that if you're 35 and single and
you want to have kids you better find
the guy like immediately ladies
and and there's so I think there's kind
of this um I remember I remember being
young like being really young and
feeling like 40 was really old
you remember like that feeling of like
what 40 felt like when you were 20. and
you were like I've been 40 for three
years now Dave so I guess so well you're
really experiencing it uh but like you
remember that and then and it almost
feels like if you're that's like the end
like 40 is the end you know but it's not
it's the halfway point and so like it
might feel great at 25 to be like oh I
don't need a family I don't need kids
like okay but how are you gonna feel at
55 60 65 70 75 when other people have
their kids and their families around
them and you have like nothing and you
know the the tragic thing about it is
that there's no going back at that point
like you've kind of got to figure this
out now and so it's awful that we don't
like how do we how do we not as a
culture like promote to young people
that the best thing you can do is get
married and have a family
too and then and then I'm gonna I'm
gonna give you the best thing for me is
get married my wife Sheena best ever
happened in my life is marrying my wife
I got married at 21 22 years old coming
out the military have my son at 22 years
old got divorced at 22 years old filed
bankruptcy at 22 years old
PTSD 22 years a big remember we're
moving our boxes I show you my PTSD
certificate they went to the shredder to
shred I wish I kept it but I'm going
through all this stuff and some of the
worst dark moments in a man's life is
knowing that your children just got
ripped away from your house that you
have to be told by the courts when to
see your kids that the courts say you
pick your kids up in the Walmart here
the parking lot you meet here and like
you have supervised visitation all this
[__] yeah and when you see the uh
your child support money going and it's
not going to the child
so men will look at it that way and
that's the way I looked at it so for me
I did a deep dive into my faith when I
looked at that Wall Street Journal that
this is when I started going to Calvary
Church and uh you know I was at uh in
Orange County Calvary Church uh what's
that mall there
um in South Coast Plaza right there yeah
Raw Reese and Greg Laurie he was out
there they had Bible studies on Mondays
and they're talking about the design of
marriage I'm like well I've never heard
of this stuff before and so I wasn't
around the example of husband and wife
together raising uh being raised by a
kid now granted my father was around he
was there but typical Filipino dad never
said anything until you did something
wrong right and then I learned how to
just not talk to my father because I
didn't want to be told I was doing wrong
but if you're looking at
um my 14 years after I got divorced I'm
just gonna I'm just gonna do my thing I
focused on my business 14 years
she's gonna come she's gonna come now as
a man I felt I could wait build my
business I could wait evolved because I
felt more confident as a husband if I
was a provider and a protector if I
wasn't providing if I was protecting
I wouldn't feel good as a man and then
maybe remember we got uh we decided to
get married so let's just go into our
pastor's office and just do the swearing
and our mothers found out like Oh no
you're not going to do that makes you
know family comes in we spent how much
is our budget for our wedding
thousand bucks how much is your wedding
dress
100 bucks for a wedding dress
are saving the money or what save that
money are waiting downstairs everything
was everybody's pumped up excited I mean
it was to me I'm Jim biased to it but we
just felt that was an awesome wedding
that is so cool would you mind talking
to my wife
just maybe you guys hang out a little
bit together the best thing she said
babe you know what I don't care about uh
uh spending money on her wedding I'd
rather invest in her marriage
hey Pat she has a brother I think I
think she has a brother or I'll take
what I can get
I don't care
I'm getting a prenup though Sheena but
you said something very interesting Dave
that you said um the the best
environment to raise children is with a
dual family dual parent household right
pbd you did an entire episode about this
that
the second best is actually with a
single father that the stats are
actually quite comparable to a dual
parent household to the that of just a
man raising a child and then it just
plummets if it's a single mom what was
that what was that yeah that's what it
was like like the power of having a
father figure in your life uh uh it's a
difference like if the house already pad
there's no there's no accountability
when you're just raised with your mom is
funny me and my wife are just having
this conversation yesterday
we're just talking about the path
there's no accountability because
there's nobody keeping you in check the
mother just wants to nurture you all
you're okay what happened to you you're
screamed let me help you the dad's like
nah you got to quit that [__] real
fast you got to get the best you can see
Angie your mom having an easy time
raising you and Allah you guys look like
you guys are too sweet little boys you
listened you didn't break the rules I'm
in jail again
[Applause]
you have nobody to answer to in the
natural order I think a lot of people
don't realize it's the natural order of
life is you know as God we we answered
the man a man doesn't that doesn't
answer is not accountable to God has
nothing to live for because he has
nothing to base his life on so the
natural order is God the matter the head
of the household and the wife and then
the kids and when you disrupt that
natural order of life you're done
there's no way you're gonna have a
healthy life if you continue to live
that way so to me it's like yeah of
course it makes sense the single fathers
are raising better kids and single
mothers not because moms suck at is
because a dad needs to be there to have
an accountability over that child the
fact that I got in trouble so much was
because my dad was not there my dad's
not a deadbeat was around but my dad I
just felt like I get away with with more
because that was not there to to uh to
tell me yeah you can or you can't do
this or whoop my ass like he did when I
was around them all the time he kept me
in check so yeah it makes total sense
yeah I I would also just add to this
because I agree with everything you guys
have been saying and I think it's very
true that one of the things that uh
disincentivizes men uh from wanting to
get married is kind of these artificial
so legal liabilities
exactly so there's no question because
of the kids um but there's also there's
there's other aspects to it as well and
I like I would because I'm obsessed with
politics so this is what I focus on but
there's also aspects where direct
government policies have disincentivized
families and not just the fact that for
years like say the rise of the welfare
state for years they were straight up
cutting you a check if you had kids
without a dad in the house and this is
just like you know yeah and this is just
basic economics 101 that if you
incentivize a behavior you will get more
of it than you otherwise would have
that's just the way that's the way
things work on top of that the policies
of um sucking kids into this college
trap and and artificially bidding up the
prices of college which is all loans
backed by the government guaranteed by
the government you know if you if some
18 year old kid here who has no some
some 18 year old who has no income and
no assets and no work history three
walked in and said I want a loan for two
hundred thousand dollars to start a
business you will get laughed out of the
bank it would be like there is no chance
that you could find a bank to give you
that loan but if you go in there and say
I want it for college boom rubber stamps
here you go no problem sending you into
debt it's the most vicious uh type of
debt it's worse than credit card debt
they can Garner your wages over it
bankruptcy to get rid of it then at the
same time we've had policies uh such as
artificially low interest rates the the
Federal Reserve buying mortgage-backed
Securities on a regular basis that have
bid up the price of housing so you now
you have these guys you know it's like
these 25 year olds Who come out of
college they kind of did what all the
adults around them were telling them is
the right thing to do they're 150 Grand
in debt the average price of a home is
like eight hundred thousand dollars and
the kid works at Starbucks and he's like
well how the hell am I ever going to get
married and like provide for a wife and
a family and and to be fair this is part
of the reason why so many of those kids
start demanding socialism and I kind of
as much as that's not the direction we
want to go and you kind of understand
where the the corruption in the system
has failed so much that they're like
well this is impossible like how could I
ever get out of them they've also
probably been on you know crazy
psychiatric drugs I also think there's
one other issue uh especially among
younger people and that's hookup culture
and
um I quite frankly have been a good
benefactor of some of this hookup
culture but women now
women now view themselves as yeah if the
guys can do it I can do it and I think
we can all agree there's a big
difference between a guy sleeping with a
bunch of women versus a woman sleeping
with a bunch of men and that's that that
is pervasive among amongst women and
it's it's sort of
ruining women's
um asset right in the marketplace and
it's asset value that's right asset
values with that a double s e t all
right but it's it it men and women are
not equal in that regard you caught me
on that one it makes sense why he's
single by the way yeah it totally makes
sense but I'm a man with options is
there any signs you get of uh the desire
to one day get married yes or no any
signs like give me this much of a sign
yes or no Adam no science here but it's
just no sign I've been the benefactor of
part of the hookup culture myself Mr
Tinder swipe right Elite Yelp or no no
dating apps that's another thing by the
way let me go to the next one I'll just
keep hooking up with these stories okay
all right so next one here all right
Americans are moving to Japan okay
it's safety and affordability Insider
Story by the way can you guys imagine
Ricky living in Japan
uh what's your name you know
the number of Americans relocating to
Japan has seen a steady rise with 66-42
individuals making a move in 2022 the
population of American expat expats in
Japan has reached 60 804 a significant
increase of 57 000 in 2020 according to
the country's Ministry Justice wow
safety is a primary motivator for
Americans shooting Japan as their new
home as Veronica Hanson who moved to
Japan with her family explains my
children had to do active shooter drills
I just exploded and said we don't have
to stay here let's go the country's
reputation for safety and minimal
presence of gun violence provides a
sense of security affordability is
another key factor driving the migration
Alex Evans who moved to rural mukai
Shima Island emphasizes the cost
advantages saying for a three-bedroom
house I pay 65 000
65 000 Yen which is the same as 463
dollars a month if I were in Hiroshima
my rent would be more expensive so any
consideration of wanting to move to
Japan Ricky I'll go to your first I have
a well you know what I wanted to go what
I would want to see Pat
how many of those are Japanese Americans
versus just Americans so keep in mind
this is an Insider story right Insider
story is is is typically leaning left so
the the story they're trying to say I
don't know if you caught two or three
comments they made you know training and
you know I have to be careful with this
and be careful with that so all this
stuff about America this is why I want
to go over there yeah I think it's look
here's here's what we have behind things
I love Mexico when we go you know me and
Erica we have property makes we have
family in Mexico I love Mexico Mexico's
uh when it comes out to gun violence is
is a lot more dangerous than America is
right because a lot of people don't know
that you can't it's not legal to carry
guns in Mexico but yet all the criminals
in Mexico care have the guns and they
out sometimes many times in in in in
gunfights they outdo the military in
Mexico
um and so but I would still not want to
move to Mexico though it's supposedly
you know uh that's home or whatever it
is it's the motherland but I wouldn't
want to go back
um how come safety no no
just because this is this is like like
okay good you could you could you could
live in Japan for 400 bucks a month
where's your life going to go what
Legacy You're Gonna Leave Behind like
how many people are building business
over there you can say wow look what
they left for their kids like I'm
looking at Pat right now we went to his
house to go have dinner earlier by the
way incredible dinner Pat um I don't
even know what Saturday at the beginning
which is like a bunch of green stuff I'm
like [__] it I'm just gonna eat it you
know some meatballs and then yeah and I
saw meatballs I'm like I'm going for
that immediately but it was you know so
anyway so I'm like you know Pat has a
couple you know guys security guards
here he lives in a good neighborhood you
have to say you're like his guards are
his uh his his there's people in his uh
uh his gate before you go in they're
armed there's people going around 24
hours like bro why don't you just build
a business and go live in a safer
neighborhood like I don't have to worry
about that happening in my neighborhood
I live in a gated neighborhood it's 24
hour security I don't ever think about
or my nephew's gonna get killed by gun
violence that it's just you might you
might the only place I would have to
worry about that is where I grew up at
East Bakersfield well that makes sense
but why don't you go instead of running
away from building something big why
don't you stay where you're at build
something big and get out of the
neighborhood potentially can have those
things happen because like this whole
shooting oh there's guns every that's a
bunch of [__] it's not true yeah we
have a lot of guns everywhere but they
also don't tell you how many times guns
are prevented uh mass murders and how
they protect their families you go to
Japan yeah cool bro you may nobody has
guns but the government can turn on you
whenever you want like it's so crazy to
think that giving the power the
government that much power over you and
some people literally want to do that is
that's excruciating to my brain to think
that that you will only want the
government to have power over who
controls the guns still everybody every
time that's worked out um every time
that has happened it's never worked out
good for the population so no I wouldn't
I wouldn't move I don't care I don't
care if gun viners win up by 100 in
America I still want to move because I
can still move to a safer neighborhood
and I could have security like you do
and that's it that's that's you know all
that does it have to really Resort so
yeah yeah bro we're humans that's what
has to be resort to people have been
killing each other do you guys forget
the first murder in human history was
Adam and E I mean I'm sorry and Caden
Abel it was one brother killing the
other you're never gonna run away from
this [__] like come on get real bro like
people are gonna kill each other matter
where you go for a second there I
thought Adam killed Eve I'm sorry
think about this the first like the
first murder murder in human history
were God's grandchildren literally
they were like it's like Adam and Eve
thank God that was Grandpa his grandkids
killed each other and you think that
you're you're gonna run away from this
when there's part of our DNA no matter
where you go in the world I I sometimes
you guys forget that Japan went to China
and threw that you would throw the
babies up in the sky and would catch
them with baronets with the knives on
their guns like you don't know your
history if you think Japan is so
peaceful how about you I also have a
very bad history when it comes on to
that they wanted to try to throw him up
in the air and would catch him with the
knife of their baronets read your
history books even still want to move to
Japan yeah my father was born during
World War II and he was two years old
and was taught during World War II by my
older my aunt his older sister how to
play dead in the streets in Manila
because the Japanese go through the the
city and band and everything in my life
the Japanese the Japanese there and
there was absolutely vicious one of the
most ruthless militaries ever they have
been a lot cooler since then but they
were pretty bad they were pretty bad for
a while just for the record so during my
time in the Marine Corps I got stationed
there for a year so I lived in Japan for
a year in Okinawa
and uh I could tell you this about about
uh Japanese people very disciplined yeah
they're very kind people
um they they love their family I mean if
you talk about Safety and Security and
education by the way you see the way
Japanese teach the kids how much further
Advance they are in terms of intellect
and understanding subject matters their
way out there so you know if you're
looking at a a safe country to go to
where your money can go I mean people
leave
all the time to come America yep we're
facing a time right now people are
leaving America I can't tell how many
times in our office we do we do booms on
a weekly basis twice a week in our
offices I can tell many times people are
saying you know what let me go to uh
Panama let me go to Belize let me go to
uh you know Japan Singapore let me leave
America because the product of America
isn't as shiny and strong and attractive
as it once used to be and it hurts me
because I'm a patriot I've served this
country and I love our home but people
aren't thinking about I got a guy dming
right now because he's not wanting to
leave Thailand he's in Padia Beach
Thailand he loves Thailand and when
you're looking at these these stats when
you're looking at other countries making
themselves attractive to Americans yeah
if we wait what do you say Patrick if
you don't take care of your people
somebody else will somebody else will
I'll say one thing um
I love America like amen I mean I love
this country born and raised in this
country
um my great-grandparents fled the
[__] Bolshevik Revolution
grandparents fled Nazi Germany like I
love America I'm so thankful that I'm
born in America what did Jamie dimon say
about America recently like we were
dealt an amazing hand we have uh
peaceful Neighbors on the North Canada
Mexico besides Ricky and then we got we
have the Atlantic Ocean and we have the
Pacific Ocean we have capitalism we have
free markets it's amazing situation that
we have here and rather than
Cut and Run and move to a different
country that's what I think is so
amazing about what we do here having
these conversations how can we improve
our country we are still the greatest
country on Earth okay by far and it's
incumbent on all of us to have these
types of conversations what can we do to
improve because the politicians equate
on both sides are [__] it up their
approval ratings are in the dust bin and
it's um I think that's what's so
powerful what we do here so
um let's figure this thing out yeah you
know I'm part of stories like this when
you read it you know you have no idea
how many of these guys move there
because of covet because of school and
because of Education because of families
because of military because of a job
opportunity because of you know one of
the uh when you were in the army people
wanted to go to Japan to be English
teachers and school teacher was an easy
job to have and you're right next to
Okinawa was a good base it was a great
place to find a wife it's lesser of a
hookup culture so maybe not good for you
but uh Japan you've said something that
I just want to bring up yeah yeah
yeah you don't get upset I'm sure
there's some hooking up going on there I
know you don't want to get upset about
it but zero big skin
um
you give in the restaurant analogy about
America yes and that still Rings true
and you've also brought up the number
one concern for a mother parents but
mother specifically is their children
safe for sure like if your kids are not
safe yeah you're gonna move
countries the restaurant analogy I think
is still uh very very good analogy that
you use about America I don't know if
you want to explain that
America's got a waiting room of people
wanting to come here leading the world
with 41 million immigrants that are here
there's no such thing as the Russian
dream or the you know Japanese dream or
the Chinese dream there's only the
American dream and that's going to be
there but the part about that is we have
to do our part to keep it that way
correct you know uh Yankees they haven't
won a you know what do you call a triple
three since one 2009 right I just got a
new owner
[Applause]
but you think about it you think that
Steinbrenner over here you think about
it in in any place you're in for you to
be arrogant to think it's going to be
like this forever you're a fool yeah so
sometimes when you and I were having
this conversation together about uh you
know I think there's three communities
that are ruining America today and we've
been talking about this a lot and I keep
saying it over and over and over again
the three communities these are the
tolerant Christians that they're sitting
around saying well it's okay let them do
it it's okay it's okay it's okay it's
okay it's okay no it's not okay that's
not how it's supposed to be it's the uh
lazy and scared Republicans or
conservatives that they're not putting
their money where their mouth is you're
complaining about what's going on and
look at the mainstream media look how
much control they got look at what these
guys are doing at Washington Post and a
Time Magazine and I this this that you
got plenty of money why don't you go buy
them out these guys are buying them
you're not they're buying everything
then just be quiet or compete get at the
damn Arena
something about it if you're not sit the
you know what down and don't say
anything especially with all that money
in your bank account because the others
if there's one thing I got from uh
Anthony Weiner today is the following
forget about where he's at everything
about him was well that's a good
strategy well that's a good strategy
well that's what worked and this is what
worked he was only thinking about
strategy it wasn't like you know well
that's exactly what we're gonna do to
win over here and then we have to go get
this person and that person if we get
this person it was so much of our
strategy where the writers like look man
we belong to this country club we're
good with this with that we don't need
to do all the other stuff and then the
last one is with my friend here
uh uh the libertarian everybody wants to
see run for office Dave Smith is to do
your thing Libertarians they're also
part of the problem because there's too
much of sitting there saying it's it's
listen as long as you leave me alone and
you let me do what I'm doing I'm good
the problem is they're not leaving you
alone they're going around you to go to
your kids I asked the question today
from Anthony Weiner it was one of the
most uncomfortable questions to him I
don't know did anybody watch the entire
podcast or no who watched the whole
thing did anybody watch a beginning
today and ahore I know you did
do you want to repeat what I asked him
because this is my family here but I
think if you say it it's okay with a
straight look on my face I look at
Anthony Weiner and can you pull up that
article first before I ask this question
you know which one I'm talking about
yemen.com go to the word queer and pull
it up and ask him this question it got
so uncomfortable George you ready for
this question it's a very uncomfortable
question it's very good because if I ask
you this question you would be like what
the hell is the matter with them so Adam
what question did I ask him I believe
you asked him when you were 10 or 12
years old were
um people teaching you how to no no
that's not what I asked them I asked
them right there I can say it if you
want I don't care
we're having dinner you said you said uh
uh are you are you any good at doing
blow jobs
and he looked at you I guess he kind of
offended and Confused yeah are you any
good at doing blow jobs he's like what
he said so if you don't if you it made
you uncomfortable so why would you be
asking 10 year old kids or teaching 10
year old kids through these books how to
do [__] that was a question I asked
him dang I said I said do you and I need
to learn how to give blow jobs he looks
at me like there's something wrong with
I said notice how uncomfortable you got
imagine how uncomfortable it is for
mothers to say keep those books out of
my kids faces go to this book here right
now queer that uh this this uh keep
going down this is what kids are reading
right now in many parts of the country
keep going up keep going up keep going
up uh keep going up keep going up keep
going up right there boom go up a little
bit hey hello
hello here's how you do it go a little
bit up go a little bit up go a little
bit up boys with boys boys with boys
right there fantastic boys here's how
you do it this is what happens yeah so
this is by the way to be fair even when
I asked them I said would you want your
kids he says no I want them on my 11
year old he's not even in it and his
immediate reaction is going to be what
no that doesn't make any sense for this
to happen so again but this when we went
to school this is weird some of you guys
right now are uncomfortable the fact
that I'm even bringing up these words
right
but because of tolerant Christians
because of lazy and scared Republicans
conservative and because of do your
thing Libertarians we're here so if we
think America is going to be the
greatest country forever you are naive
you're a fool but if we realize like for
it to stay the greatest kind of like for
example I watch this documentary the
only documentary I've seen Dylan cry
only one he's watched a lot of
documentaries the only one that got him
emotional where babe you'll remember
this we were in what would we have when
he watches was it Bermuda I think we
were in Bermuda so every day he needs to
whatever hour he watches of a
documentary he gets to play 30 minutes
of iPad while it's vacation time
throughout the weekday weekends they get
two hours of iPad weekday they have to
watch per hour documentary you get 30
minutes of watching a plain iPad so
anyways we're in Bermuda I said I want
you to watch this documentary this is a
day before the announcement of Yankees
has happened and so I'm getting them to
watch all the documentaries on the
Yankees so I need them to understand
what's happening with the Yankees and he
watches this documentary of Yogi Berra
okay
he watches this thing what was it called
babe what was the name of it can you
pull it up Yogi Bear documentary
he comes it ain't over oh guys you have
to watch this he comes up to me his eyes
are filled with tears he says that he
this was the best documentary ever I
said Dilly I said why I said it's the
best documentary ever so now I haven't
seen the documentary so I come back and
I watch the documentary I'm upstairs
Jen's in the room
I'm like trying to hide away from Jen
because I'm getting choked up like
multiple times like what the hell is
wrong with this documentary so emotion
with the family relationship all this
stuff but you know what the whole thing
was about
there is pride about Yogi one as a
champion then he won as a coach and he
was so proud of representing the jersey
that when steinburner fired him he says
I will never come back in the stadium
ever again and the first time him and
Don Larson I believe that through a
perfect game I think I'm saying the name
right Don Larson throw perfect game did
he throw a perfect game he threw a
perfect game and Yogi caught the perfect
game the day he and Don Larson come to
the game for the very first time do you
know who threw a perfect game that night
David Coleman
so the first time I think it's David
Cohen the first time he doesn't come to
the stadium for 20 plus years him and
the guy who were the last guys to throw
a perfect game coming that night there's
a perfect game he's like after the sixth
can you imagine how emotional that is
you're like what are the chances of this
right it's like what you wouldn't be
able to put it in a movie dude you
wouldn't be able to put this in a movie
insane odds right for this to happen
there might be one perfect game for the
whole season I remember when Kenny
Rogers threw a perfect game with the
Texas Rangers I was a die-hard Rangers
Fan but the point is you're watching
this you're like dude you got to be
proud if you played for the Yankees you
coached for the Yankees you got to be
proud of the Yankees right if you were
having any of the benefits of this great
country called America and this thing in
one way or another change your life you
are a coward if you don't do the
fighting now this is why I say those
three communities have to understand if
you don't do your part guess what very
soon people I would never move to Japan
what makes you think you won't move to
Japan my family moved here from Iran I
would never move to Japan
we are naive to think we will never one
day move to Japan if America is no
longer what America once was guys all of
us may be moving somewhere so this is
the whole reason why we you know did
what we did when we saved in America by
bringing back the free enterprise system
and hope to American families because
this is a fight worth fighting and it's
going to require everybody and those who
sit on the sidelines all of a sudden are
going to hurt this thing this great idea
that they came up with in 1776 that
changed our lives that's my only
argument we have to do our part if we
don't let's go one to be a [__] show
people well I'm sorry people what's
what's some tangible things that people
are watching so well you know Patrick I
don't have a podcast and I remember in
Bahamas there's a guy that approached to
the Bahamas and you called him out
because he wants to be on this podcast
yeah to pitch his message and his
product he said once you start your own
podcast and he said I don't want to lose
clients I don't lose business he was
there with 100 people and you said
you're part of the problem yeah and so
what but what can people really tangibly
do to stay in to stand their ground and
build America up to that promise where
we can they've said something very
interesting Dave says one day he's
watching uh the DNC and the RNC I think
he's watching the RNC and Ron Paul
speaks and Ron Paul speaks about the FED
okay he had a book at the time and the
fed or something like that right he says
I watched this guy out of everybody I
related to him he says I came back I
watched his material I read his book
then I read all his books then I read
all the books that he recommends to read
then I watch Milton Friedman then I
watch Iron rant and the next thing you
know I can't get the stuff out of my
head right so so the lowest thing
somebody can do to start off with when I
first met Ricky Ricky and I sat down I
said Ricky do me a favor tonight before
you go to sleep watch this Milton
Friedman 45 minute interview was with
Phil Donahue I believe right do you know
from that moment on
Ricky goes away on his own we don't have
a follow-up conversation the next time I
saw Ricky on stage
he delivers a 20-minute message 15
minute message and I'm like
what the hell happened to this guy he
says Pat now one video I got obsessed
and I just watched everything and then I
realized all the mistakes my parents
made Jorge Ramos people in my community
and now Ricky is baptizing other people
and he's getting other people thinking
so step number one is for you to
actually want to go through the Journey
what would you say well yeah look I mean
I think that it's don't ever
underestimate how powerful telling the
truth is it's it's an unbelievable
powerful thing to like stand up and tell
the truth and it's an unbelievably
damaging thing to bite your tongue when
you know what the truth is and I think
that's the point you are getting at I
listen to that podcast the other day
where you're talking about like kind of
particularly for people who are like
wealthy and are in a position look you
can't count on the guy who's like making
60 Grand a year to risk his livelihood
you know what I mean but if you're a guy
with like millions in the bank then like
come there's there's a little bit more
of an onus on you so like you can step
up you can take the arrows you know what
I mean you're already you're already
protected to some degree great so why
did you respond to his podcast you react
to him on July 4th during the night
because what you need a podcast or you
recorded that podcast reaction to his
point oh the well the point well the
thing that we are talking about the the
uh the point of these three groups who
have kind of like allowed this problem
to happen and you and I talked about it
I think you you were look reacting to
McGregor was it when oh yes
Colonel Douglas McGregor that was a
great podcast as well but just just to
respond to that because I I am you know
a Libertarian and one of kind of the
more prominent libertarian uh people out
there that I I did a segment on my
podcast about this that I think you're
absolutely right and I think that like
essentially I'm a Libertarian and to me
what that means is that I believe people
have natural rights like I believe
people have natural rights and that it's
immoral to violate their rights and
among these rights like the right to
life liberty property like you know
essentially what it is is the the idea
of the non-aggression principle that
violence is legitimate and self-defense
but it's not legitimate to initiate
violence against peaceful people and I
also happen to recognize that free
market free market capitalism leads to
the most prosperous societies we have
lots of good empirical evidence on this
look at East Germany versus West Germany
North uh Korea versus South Korea these
are places that share the exact same
culture the same genetics the same
everything the only thing that was
different were their economic systems
and one produces starvation and the
other produces enormous wealth it's okay
so because you're now what a lot of
Libertarians kind of got in the tendency
of doing was because you have the right
to do what you want to do and you have
the right to do what you want to do
therefore I shouldn't care about what
you're doing I shouldn't care what
you're doing with your freedom but
that's not actually that doesn't
actually logically follow like it's also
well within my rights to object to what
you're doing to be intolerant of what
you're doing and there has to be a
certain point like tolerance is good to
a certain degree you know if there's
somebody in this room who's a Christian
and there's somebody in this room who's
a Muslim and there's someone who's an
atheist it's good that we all respect
hey you have a right to that view I
respect that you don't force your view
on me I don't force your view my view on
you but you get to a certain point where
we're literally talking about
introducing blow job instructions to
children and you're like no like there
can be no tolerance of this and the fact
that it's gotten to this point
demonstrates we have been way too
tolerant like the idea that we ever that
we were not up in arms well before this
was even introduced into schools like
first off I would argue that that's
that's an act of aggression like that's
children this is an activity yes
um but but just aside from that you
realize that it's like they're so so
where exactly is the point when we need
to not be tolerant anymore I don't know
but let me just adventure to say it's
several steps before teaching [__]
to Children you know what I mean like
several steps before that is where we
need to be like I have a question for
you Dave okay I have a question for you
though sure let me give you the flip
side of it okay
a child giving you a [__]
I'm sorry is that inappropriate I'm a
dirty comedian from New York
that is the reverse no let me give you
the flip side of it
how about all these people there's only
one party pushing this [__] okay and
that's a fact
well there's one party pushing it and
there's one party being completely
complicit I agree with you
but here's my point
my point is this there's only one party
pushing it not the other party's not
fighting it but one party's pushing it
okay what about the people that keep
voting for that party that keeps doing
that [__] what responsibility do
they have you call yourself a Christian
you call yourself you're you know you
say that you're believing God that
you're a person of Faith but your party
not only owns slaves not only supported
Jim Crow not only uh supported the KKK
not only voted for LBJ that said I'm
gonna have these ends voting Democrat
for 200 years uh not only uh fought the
Civil Rights not only did all of that
okay it's the same party that's pushing
this [__] how much responsibility
should people take for voting for the
same party that keeps pushing this
[__] they have 200 years of [__]
like so at what point okay I get you I
have to fight these people off I'm good
fighting people that knowingly want to
do it that knowingly want to teach this
kids this [__] I have a problem with
also fighting people that are so goddamn
stuck in their [__] ways excuse my
language that you are still voting for
these people I don't mind fighting my
real enemies I hate fighting blind
enemies the ones that I can't see that
you call yourself a Christian a head of
a household then you call yourself a
leader but you too you you cannot even
fathom the idea that what your auntie
and your granny and your mommy taught
you is complete [__] [__] at what
point do I have to fight them too why
can't they wake up why can't they do
their homework why can't they see what
they've been doing why do I have to take
responsibility for them as well that's
the problem that I have so I'm good
again show me I I you know when I ask
God for one thing David Dave not David
Dave I asked God for one thing
protect me from my friends I can handle
my enemies
yeah no listen I get your point and look
so I can't take responsibility for that
bro well there's I fight by the way I
live in California I don't meet your
trip to you sir I'm staying in
California and you know when I get asked
why because I'm gonna keep fighting that
[__] I'm gonna I'll pay the 50 tax
so I can find my [__] running bro I'm
staying right there bro I'm gonna take
this [__] to the I'm gonna go I'm gonna
die with this I'm gonna take this all
the way to the ground so but why do I
gotta fight people that call themselves
Christians or Catholics or whatever
religion and keep voting for the same
party doing this [__] it's obvious
who's doing it at this point like why
don't why are you still my enemy too
like bro these are people you're voting
for you know what's funny I will tell
you the sign with this David and I'll
finish with this I told babe what I tell
you about uh Rob uh our RFK he's the
only one that I'll ever do what remember
I told you
I said the RFK is the only Democrat I
can see myself ever voting for I'm even
willing to switch for RFK I am not stuck
so much in the Conservative Republican
party because I see this man on my dude
this guy's solid you know how many
Democrats can't do that the other way
even though they're they're so willing
to go down the road with this [__]
there's a reason for that I think Dave
you ought to break it down uh from the
standpoint so I have a Fernando loss
over on my place he's from Ecuador
the singer the famous singer yes so he's
at the house he was my groom someone at
my wedding and one of the greatest
pranks I've pulled in my life was on
Fernando hands down it's got to be the
top 10 greatest prank that's incredible
if you're afterwards after we're done
I'll tell you guys a story it's a great
prank anyway so he starts talking about
Korea Korea is the guy that's going to
be coming back to run against the guy
that they have right now who's a
conservative Korea was the one that's
like a Castro type of a figure he's
coming back and he's probably gonna end
up winning the election next two months
he's super worried he has no idea what
to do am I going to leave am I going to
do this am I going to do that and he
starts on well I've always been a
Democrat but I'm starting to think I'm a
Republican and I don't know what I am
and he's kind of going back and forth I
said lasso you know it's no longer it's
no longer about being a democrat or a
republican because what you just said
has nothing to do with Democrat and
Republican and and you will take it from
here I'll give it to you is it's more
from establishment to anti-establishment
for example
Anthony Weiner is a Democrat but is an
establishment Democrat with Hillary
Clinton because she's full-blown
establishment but also the bushes are
established 100 McConnell 100
establishments so you can go and give a
lot of Republicans that are part of the
establishment the people you have to
look at are the anti-establishment
candidates okay now here's a problem
with the anti-establishment candidates
the anti-establishment candidates
typically get assassinated or they get
eliminated so if you look at
anti-establishment so you got Andrew
Jackson the first ever
anti-establishment guy is Andrew Jackson
uh we can talk about our founding
fathers going again
Abraham Lincoln but Andrew Jackson okay
then you've got Abraham Lincoln
assassinated okay John F Kennedy
anti-establishment they wanted to shut
down CIA they wanted to shut down the
FED everything
anti-establishment Ronald Reagan
somewhat anti-establishment some could
even say that Reagan was 50
establishment 50 anti-establishment then
from there at first people thought Obama
was anti-establishment but he ended up
being you know establishment Bill
Clinton well maybe this guy's
anti-establishment nope he was
establishment Trump anti-establishment
what do they want to do to Trump so now
today a clip with RFK comes out and
everybody's trying to bash him trash him
today he's trying to defend himself
saying hey what are you guys doing to
all this stuff that I'm doing so the
only reason you're saying I'm willing to
vote for a Democrat you're not willing
to vote for a Democrat Ricky you respect
those that are anti-establishment right
so it's no longer I'm a Democrat or I'm
a republican I'm an anti-establishment
person because I want to make the
decision of what's best for my family I
don't need you to make all the decision
of what's best for my family that's the
RFK part what would you add to that yeah
well like I think to your point about
like people being responsible for who
they vote for I mean look I can't argue
that there's yeah to some degree people
are responsible for who they vote for
and if you vote for somebody who's
really awful particularly if they've
already been enacting these horrible
policies and then you continue to
support that person or that party
there's there's definitely some
responsibility that falls on you for
that I do tend to focus more of my
outrage toward the powerful people who
are intentionally inflicting this on
Americans and have a little bit more
sympathy for look the fact is that
there's just been like it's not as if
Democratic voters just say woke up one
morning and decided to think it was a
good idea to force the vaccine on on
everybody in the country there was a
massive propaganda campaign where they
were really fooled I mean like they
genuinely believed they were listening
to the expert science class and look man
in a suit on CNN told me that this
doctor is giving me all of the right
information now I'm now do they have
some level of responsibility for that
sure absolutely but I also think that
there is look watch what happened with
Donald Trump the way Donald Trump just
almost look for people who are at least
our age for younger people maybe not uh
recognize this as much the way he
snapped the Republican base out of you
have to support every foreign war like
they were I mean if you talked to your
average Republican voter in 2007 and you
said like oh I don't think we should
have fought the war in Iraq Afghanistan
I don't think we should be fighting any
of these wars they were like what are
you some type of loon what are you some
left-wing hippie everybody knows that we
had to go fight these wars and we had to
do this because we love our country and
in one second Donald Trump gave all of
them permission to just be like no you
don't have to believe that hey you were
lied too and they went oh you know what
we were kind of lied too about that and
I I give Ron Paul a lot of credit for
this too I think Ron Paul standing up
there and saying this in 2008 and 2012
gate led the way for Donald Trump to
come out and say it and I think in a way
look RFK is pulling consistently at
about 20 percent within the Democratic
base and he represents a complete
repudiation of everything Biden stands
for I mean Biden's biggest policies were
the vax Mandate and this crazy war in
Ukraine and RFK is like yep completely
against both of those I I agree with you
but here's the thing though if JFK was
alive right now would it be a Democrat
it's always one party that has the most
of this [__] going on and that's
just a fact
I'll give you a pushback on that because
I'll tell you that look immediately in
in the aftermath of 9 11 the Republicans
were absolutely horrible on a national
level
let's not get away from the subject the
schools yes
the reason why Dave jumped in you said
the one side has always been on the
wrong side no no I said they've always
pushed a lot of this [__] the other
side I'm making the point that there's
Evolution with these parties right so at
the time act while George W bush and
Dick Cheney were instituting torture
they were pushing us into disastrous
Wars it was actually the Democrats who
were saying things like which Obama was
saying was part of the reason why he got
elected even though he didn't follow
through on any of that that we should
repeal the Patriot Act we should close
Guantanamo Bay we shouldn't get involved
in all these stupid Wars this was a
message that was very appealing to a lot
of Voters but it was all alive well
whether it turned out whether it was a
lie or whether they were spying on their
opposition yeah and we know there's
nothing but this is now you're fast
forwarding to 2016. but whether it was a
lie or whether Obama got rolled by
powerful interests I don't know for sure
but quite either way he didn't govern
that way I'm just making the point that
the party's kind of flipped on this
issue of war and now the Democrats are
much more of the Warhawk uh party than
they were are back in in the wake of
September 11th and so what's that one of
the things that's fascinating about RFK
and I think one of the reasons why a lot
of people get upset when he's got some
of his bad liberal positions like he's
liberal on affirmative action or he's
liberal on some of these other I'm
almost like glad he has those because I
don't want him to be a right-winger I
want him to be the best liberal I want
somebody to try to bring the Liberals
back and look we can have contempt for
the half of America that votes for the
the Democratic party but that is a that
is half of the voting base in America
and if we can't try to make them better
we're going to have a major problem in
this country good point I want to add
something before we move on to to the
next uh uh topic here you said I want to
stay in California until they burn it
down or something like that well I'll
burn with California okay perfect so you
said that all right and and you know all
the people that jump ship or whatever
you said okay I don't have anything
against them I guess that's my goal I
totally get it but here I saw people I
don't think it really is your goal I
think you're saying it it's a good
motivational thing to say but I don't
believe
uh that's how you're going to think when
you have kids going through certain
places right now let me just say of
course I just want to give you a message
for you to be thinking about it process
you're a guy that knows how to reason
and we are we have some of the best
conversations always together that's why
I love talking to you when we go
anywhere you and I are always talking to
each other the best conversations
so here's how you have to process that
um why did you leave East Baker
Bakersfield definitely I need to get
away from the bad neighborhood stuff why
not do why don't you write or die any
speaker no I agree okay so so did your
did your dad make a good move leaving
Mexico to go to Vegas so he made the
right uh uh you know choice as a father
right okay are you glad he made that
choice 100 how different would your life
have been if you were gonna be staying
in Michoacan I would probably be
probably be dead by now according to the
state one of my cousins there I'll be
dead already so you have to know that
the one part that one thing that we
don't know is trust me you know how many
places I'm in right now how many places
do you think I'm in right now where am I
right now here in five different places
of course no I'm in five places
five because my wife is here so I don't
have to worry about where she's at right
when she's not around I'm in six places
of course but I'm in five places because
I got my four other kids right right to
see where they're at when there was no
wife and there was no kid I'm in one
place of course and it's easy peasy I
gotta worry about it I'm good to go life
changes the moment that little kid you
hold in your hand and it's looking at
you crying and you're gonna call it
Ricky or whatever name you're going to
give your son or your daughter it's
going to immediately change for you all
you're going to think about is what you
can do to give the best life for this
kid decisions change in a very big way
when that takes place so for me for now
though this is where I'm at I I would
like you for you to sign a lease of an
office space as well but that's a
different conversation so that was a
personal shot I got seven offices over
there
I need you to have your own as well but
that's a different conversation so go
going going back to it I got seven more
than a lot of people
all I'm saying to you is all I'm saying
to you is this part and and then the
other thing I want you to I want you to
kind of be thinking about this I want to
go with you with this one this is one
that I've been thinking about a lot is
has here or no is is okay
he did it really not qualify you guys
been serious or no seriously is this a
joke or is this series one was like okay
cool well has
so to me
he's watching I know he is I'm a big
house fan he's he's an absolute stud him
and his wife Naveen are incredible
people but this is one thing I want to
say that's becoming very weird for me
what next thing I'm going through so my
parents they got married both Christians
one was a communist the other one was a
republican you know the other one is the
Imperial Imperial they got divorced
twice but they were both Christians
interesting huh so when people would ask
me to say what council can he give on
marriage I would say if you can do
double which is what same Faith same
political beliefs you increase the
chances of course you gotta have magic
enjoy each other's company attracted all
the other stuff but I'm just saying
philosophically okay I can only imagine
if Jen was a socialist it would never
because it wouldn't work she wouldn't
let me raise the boys the way I want to
raise them right the other day we were
at dinner with Tom Tom will remember
this we're at dinner to celebrate Kim's
uh birthday and we were a very private
conversation we were having he knows
exactly what it is and in one of the
moments she's in tears we have to make a
very big decision in our life it's not
an easy one it's a very hard one right
now we're going through
and she just looks and Tom says what are
you thinking about this whole thing and
she says
Tom
I trust my husband
I trust whatever he says this is what
we're going to be doing because his
decisions have been great with me and I
trust where he's going to take our
family
let me tell you
if she would have been any other way I
can't stay married we've been married 14
years I think we'll make it to 15. okay
we take it one year at a time and this
has been the message since the day we
got married we take it one year at a
time with marriage we don't have this I
will never know stop it stop being so
arrogant and acting like you're God that
you can predict the future the more it's
about one year at a time I believe the
more you're going to work into it
improve and kind of feel like you have
to do your part but I have to earn that
respect for my life okay so watch this
here's what's been happening which is
kind of weird
so my community we did a podcast one
time a guy uh uh it was the first one or
a second one God was Muslim what do you
think about the Muslim Community how
about us Muslim conservatives
and in your mind you're like oh shoot
you know Muslim you know
okay great no problem so let's go a
little bit deeper my dad well my sister
is getting married to Seal Mag and his
family wants to come because he wants to
ask for
you know her hand
my dad and I got into a massive argument
and he says
you're okay with your sister marrying a
Muslim
are you okay with your daughter marrying
a Muslim I said Dad
I would be okay I would be more okay
with my sister marrying a Muslim where
they share all the other common values
then I am her marrying a an Assyrian who
disrespects her doesn't treat her well
and they don't have the same values now
they got married they did a Baha'i
ceremony in the wedding and they did a
Christian ceremony they went behind
closed doors it was World War Three but
we acted very well there's politics in
relationships and all that stuff what's
the moral of the story I think there's
something crazy going on right now can
you imagine if conservative
Muslims Christians
Jews
scientologists Catholics Jehovah
seven-day LDS
Mormon LDS
if these guys come together they're like
look man who you believe in I believe in
L Ron Hubbard more power to you who you
believe in I believe in Jesus who you
believe in I believe in Abraham I
believe in this who you believe in I
believe in Virgin Mary
all good man I believe in Joseph Smith
listen to each his own we can have that
debate at a whole different time but
right now do you believe they should
keep these books out of space there you
go check I do do you believe we should
get married and have kids after getting
married and do the check do you believe
we should check do you believe in these
principles do you believe we need to
stay strong in our country yeah do you
believe I do hey guys can we just come
together because do you know crazy stat
70 percent of Muslims vote Democrat
did you know that
let me say this one more time to you 70
of Muslims vote Democrat why do they
vote Democrat you know why one reason
one reason because Republicans are known
for being what pro-israel
I know America is typically pro-israel
but it's more on the Republican side
right
so why are the what what value of the
Democrat you know the side of all this
stuff what values of those do you think
Muslims agree with none none so watch
what happened in the last midterms you
ready crazy number
excuse me 2018 midterms
only 17 percent of Muslims voted
Republican
2022 midterms 28 Muslims are up 11
percent so watch what's going on right
now if we sit there and say man I've
always had this animosity or not even
animosity what's the word stereotype or
whatever no by the way some of the story
types are right we had some of them are
perhaps terrorists and middle easterners
okay you know fine people joke with me
you know typically about somebody saying
that's a terrorist black guy you know
he's on the internet kind of doesn't go
to get us mainly from one place so we
did this video measuring what are the
top five angriest countries in the world
you know what number one was Lebanon
number two was Turkey you know what
number three was which makes all the
sense in the world Armenians okay so
it's Lebanon these are some pissed off
people right now now it makes sense for
a lot of people saying no wonder Pat's
pissed off I'm Armenian though what do
you want me to do the Armenians were
pissed off that they were number one
turkey because turkey is right above
them right oh especially but but when
you go look at the data like okay some
of the stereotype makes sense but what
if like all the people that kind of got
conservative values that are not getting
to 35 38 40 years old got kids going to
private school you're like now you're
going to what if we unite yes you got to
cross all good dog you got nothing no
problem you got Dianetics do your thing
you got the Quran let's unite to defend
our kids against this madness by the way
if that happens oh my God
go ahead and say something to Muslims
and the Muslim is going to say go ahead
and say something to my Christian
brother go ahead
do you notice what happens and now the
Dynamics there's a Synergy going on and
once you bring Synergy with the people
that they have for decades wanted to
keep divided because the more divided we
are the more they can control us the
more we realize listen what do you think
about all this stuff if this were to
happen with these communities well I I
think you're really on to something I
also think to some degree it is
happening and it's not just like the the
numbers you mentioned with Muslims but
even if you look at look Trump in 2020
was way up with his share of uh the
black vote way up with his share of the
Latino vote from his presidential
election in 2016 and a lot of this stuff
is just
um it's simply just the leftover playing
their hand and pushing a lot of people
away like you know the idea that like
you know there's still there's a lot of
black people and Latinos who are like
yeah I don't really like lockdowns and
riots
like I don't really like that mixed with
this crazy sexualization of children
like that you know what I mean and
what's interesting about this idea right
is that so the Democratic base is kind
of like this random collection of
different like minority groups who they
all kind of push together and this
you'll hear Democrats talk about this
they'll be you know they'll say things
like the disenfranchised people or you
know um something like that you know
they'll be like uh African-Americans and
Latinos the lgbtq community and you're
like first why are those all lumped
together like there's there is nothing
in common in these communities there's
no reason like I don't know if you've
like like I grew up in Brooklyn I kind
of like was around a diverse group of
people like go into the hood and start
talking to black people about lgbtq
people and tell me what kind of
responses you get you know what I'm
saying like it makes no sense so they
have this like kind of loose Coalition
and it's all built around well they are
the racist white people
and therefore you should all be voting
this way because of that but it's very
loose like there's nothing that really
ties them together look even LGBT
there's nothing that really ties them
together
they talk about it like it's a community
first off they're not a community
they're not an organic Community they're
amongst all of us there's like gays and
lesbians are not really any more
together than like straights and gays
are in fact you could argue they're
Polar Opposites you know what I mean
like um transgender has nothing to do
with being gay or lesbian it's a
completely different thing so they kind
of force all of these groups together
but it's just held on to by these kind
of like vague lies about how there's
this like oppressive racism that's out
there that was my point that I was
making earlier
that well yes that I agree with you
pushing the woke stuff and there's
another party that's impotent to kind of
stand up against it I agree with you on
that but what you're proposing here Pat
is much more of like actually let's pull
a lot of those groups together but
around something like around a common
view yeah around a belief that like Hey
listen we're opposed to this woke
Insanity we don't want this being pushed
on our children we believe in free
market cap capitalism we believe in in
individual liberty we don't believe in
fighting Wars all over the world while
our own country has fallen safety
protection for our families yeah like
like if we could just come together on
those issues I think that could be a
very strong Coalition also I'd add in
the fact that there are what the RFK win
kind of represents is that like there
are there is this Camp of good liberals
who are waking up and or good leftists
who are waking up who didn't buy the
woke stuff that does exist if you don't
think so like they all they all call
them right Wingers now but people like
Glenn Greenwald and Jimmy Dore and RFA
yeah Logan yeah Joe Joe Rogan is a
liberal you know what I mean they
consider him like something
yeah I think I think he's I think he's
he's somebody who's kind of in that camp
who's who's waking up to the insanity
but all of those guys like we we also
gotta find areas where we have agreement
with them on I'm not saying we're going
to agree with them on everything but you
got to find areas of agreement and that
I think there's a lot of potential in
that and and by the way we have no
choice we got to try to save this
country like Pat was saying before it's
like look this is the greatest country
in the history of the world we're still
the greatest country in the world
despite all the problems that we have
right now but that's not just because
like we're on magical land or something
what are we saving you from because what
are we saving it from yeah well the
enemies of Liberty well who are the
enemies of Liberty who are the enemies
of Liberty tyrants who are the tyrants
well you want like their last names no
no I'm just like who are they no no the
reason I asked this question is because
the people that are watching some of
them are so oblivious they don't know
who's who so so like if you're okay I'm
new to this question to this subject
let's say I'm new to it you and me are
not new to it I'm new to it who who's
the enemy who's the Tyrant well
assistant well I mean look you can like
you know what is a woman what is a
tyrant well a tyrant is anybody who is
is violating people's individual liberty
and so right now there's no question
that it's it's hard to even say Joe
Biden it's the people around Joe Biden
who are pushing these these insane
policies but look you have entire what
what we have what we've seen through
covet what we've seen through uh the
last 20 years of war you have these this
Unholy alliance between private
interests and government where you have
the military-industrial complex they
have this entire system where weapons
companies are funding think tanks that
then Lobby for Wars based off lies but
to rake in hundreds of billions of
dollars for those weapons companies same
with pharmaceutical companies same with
the entire banking complex where you
have this insane system where every
freaking treasury secretary is a former
Goldman Sachs employee and then just
happens to you know like uh
um has policies that benefit all the
banks that they're a part of Janet
Yellen the FED reserves so war will
stimulate the economy yes war and
abortion will stimulate the economy
according to Janet Yellen um so what
what needs to be done is there has to be
an actual draining of the swamp this is
what Donald Trump promised and this
might rub some people the wrong way but
this is what he failed to deliver on
okay now at least he promised at least
he talked about it but there's really no
question that he did not deliver on that
the swamp still exists the swamp
swallowed up Donald Trump much more than
Donald Trump ever drained the swamp so
what we need I believe is like we need a
mass Awakening of as many American
people as possible that's why I think
shows like this are so important and
what we need are it's kind of like a
three-prong strategy okay like we need
um we need a mass Awakening of people we
need Elites to get in the game I'm
talking about very wealthy people very
influential people a good example of
this is what Elon Musk just did with
Twitter not everybody can do that not
everybody what did he uh buy it for was
it 44 billion not everybody if you asked
me to come up with 44 billion I'd need a
few weeks you know what I mean like I
feel I was able to come up with the full
course
I'd have to call a lot of friends
not anyone can do that and then just
about and the other strategy is going to
have to be some type of political
strategy I'm a big fan of local uh
political power nullification on a local
level make sure you have you know it's
it's going to be tough to get the
perfect president in there but you could
get a damn good sheriff in a damn good
city councilman take over your local
schools
even DeSantis is an example of this
where look DeSantis really did something
on a state level uh that really mattered
yeah you know like was the most
important thing for your Liberty in 2020
and 2021 was not what your president was
doing it was what your governor was
doing and that's true on local levels as
well but the other thing is that we're
just gonna need it's got to be like
Donald Trump level of like bravado but
with somebody who's actually read a book
about something once and like knows what
they're talking about if I alienated
some of the Trump fans here but Donald
Trump has seen a show about a lot of
things but he hasn't read a book about a
lot of things and that's why he gave us
Anthony fauci for all of 2020. because
he was like well I'm told he's a great
guy
well number one America is the only
country in the world that is founded on
an idea every other country in the world
was founded on what geographic location
where you're at where you're at America
was founded an idea life liberty and
pursuit of happiness we don't need a
king or a ruler to basically dictate
what we do America and I need to just
sorry but even more specific than that
that go like very specifically in the
Declaration of Independence that this is
self-evident according to God he wants
men to be free that's the starting point
of the United States of America is that
I'm starting with God wants me to be
free and the only reason why government
exists is to protect my freedom correct
it's an unbelievable starting point for
a country it's not a coincidence that
that was our starting point and this
became the most successful country in
world history exactly and then to
Ricky's point you ask like who the
tyrants are I would respond with
anything with the word big in it big
Tech big Pharma big military industrial
complex big government big Lobby
anything with the big anything with big
that is consolidating power okay and the
list can go on for from that they're on
a local level brother on a local level
who is your enemy on the local who's a
tyrant on the local level city council
mayor Governor School Board School Board
who's my enemy who is my enemy and where
do they lean that's all I want to know
who's my enemy how do you vote you're my
enemy hey I'm a local I'm not talking I
can't fight a big Tech I can't fight big
Pharma not right now I can't well so
who's my enemy and where do you this is
where we differ Ricky because in Florida
here it's a very purple State I don't
have enemies here I have my neighbors I
have my friends
in California Ricky you have Meridian
privilege damn right okay
I'm just explaining to you I understand
in California well in California you
have enemies because you're you're one
of 33 of Californians who agree with you
where you have 67 percent of people who
are like [__] you I'm going woke agenda
and that's what California is falling
apart even though
Tyrese so the tyrants are clear there is
a clear line you can't tell me I can't
see my city councilman you can't see
that I can't say yeah so get involved
Ricky I'm just asking so no it's not for
me bro I know so getting the people that
don't know who is your local tyrants I
don't know my my we don't have a local
Tyrant Miami I have I have mayor Francis
Suarez
yeah but your audience that people are
watching this not just in Florida bro
it's all over the country but that's
where I live you're asking about local
so who's okay so I don't know what's
going on in California who would be a
low point of me I don't have local
enemies that's my point so I can see
where they publicly vote and then to
realize that's my enemy if they're
voting for the same [__] everybody
else let's talk let's talk about a few
things done one thing go forward and
this is I think it's very important of
what you were talking about about
conservative Muslims and all this and
everything with that Tony red I think I
am it's hot in here and I need some
water but the point is this America is
changing exponentially I got water we're
good there you go America is changing
exponentially 50 years ago if I asked
you this question
rank the following thing I've done this
on my show multiple times rank the
following three things in the order of
which is most important to you of who
you would marry race religion or
politics race would be number one a
black and a white guy oh my god oh you
know a black woman and a white guy a
black oh my God now it's the exact
opposite we see mixed race couples no
problem zero people have issues with
that number two is religion okay Jews
Muslims whatever this that Christians
this Buddhist yeah maybe you know
Hanukkah Christmas whatever but by Far
and Away the number one thing today is
kind of what Pat was saying is that
imagine a capitalist Republican
Maga person marrying a socialist woke
Democrat it just wouldn't exactly and I
would say the woke thing even more than
the Socialist thing like it'd be one
thing to be like a capitalist with a
socialist would still be pretty tough
but could you I just can't even fathom
being married to like a social justice
Warrior type check like I don't I don't
understand I don't think we could get
through an hour like there's just
there's no possible way
it's like
to do a skit about you gotta have
going to church you can't be smoking
crack like we that's just not how it
works okay so like that that's where
we're at in society today is that the
right and the left are so far removed
from each other and I actually agree
with Ricky on the Democrats especially
in California the left has gone so
freaking far left and you're talking to
a guy my dad had a picture of JFK grown
up I'm like yo JFK that's my guy I
already got shot in the head where I go
keep it moving but he banged Marilyn
Monroe cool whatever and then
I was raised in that classic liberal
type of environment and then
Obama came in and it's like all right so
the White House is now gay now all right
cool that's like and then all of a
sudden this trans stuff I'm like I'm I'm
a dude who likes to play football what's
this trans thing like so it takes like
liberals to be like like Bill Maher for
example or a Joe manchin for an example
who are Democrats but they're like yeah
we're not we're not down for all this
kind of stuff and and the the the
Democratic party has sprinted so far
left so far left that it's
unrecognizable at this point and the
problem is like you hit the nail on the
head George W bush ruined the Republican
party that's the reason why why uh
listen it's the reason why
he cut down it's also partially
responsible for why we went you know
when you're talking about how the left
went so out of control you know a lot of
this was because the George W Bush
Administration ended in such disaster
that it was almost like they had no seat
at the table anymore I mean you know
that he's the highest and lowest
approval ratings after 9 11
this might be almost hard or for I think
younger people you know like I go I do a
lot of shows and I like I have a young
audience so I'll talk to like 20 year
olds and stuff and they don't really you
know they were like babies when this was
happening well yeah but they but they
don't like remember it I'm saying that
there's you almost feel like there's the
left just controls the broader culture
but this actually was not the case
immediately following 9 11. the culture
had a very right-wing mood to it it was
very much about like patriotism and
hierarchy and Military and go America
which was a natural response to being
attacked you know and it was very much
like and essentially the American people
as you mentioned the highest approval
ratings and since we've been recording
presidential approval ratings the
American people gave George W bush a
blank check yep to fight this war on
terrorism they go you have whatever War
you want whatever action you want
whatever policy you want if you want to
group us at the airports if you want to
torture you want to open guantano obey
the Patriarchs the Department of
Homeland Security being created whatever
you want and and he spent this blank
check on two Wars in Iraq and
Afghanistan that led to the deaths of
over a million people and what what we
got for it in turn was our bravest young
men blowing their brains out by the tens
of thousands at the at the price tag of
trillions of dollars and the region
completely destabilized anyway just
nothing but I mean Raytheon got a lot
out of it you know there's a whole but
if you look in Washington DC there's a
whole bunch of millionaires out there in
Washington DC who did very well talked
about this the other day the the zip
codes with the highest uh what is it
incomes every crime that the ZIP code
with the highest crime in every category
it doesn't matter a burglary you're
talking about murder everything the
highest number one yeah is DC but the
city also with the most people making
over 200 000 a year is DC and
politically country including New York
including La Newport Beach Miami DC's
number one most people making over 200
thousand dollars so but anyway just to
my point so then after and of course now
this so this is what we get out of
George W Bush's blank check and then on
top of that his his uh his presidency
ends with the worst financial crash in a
hundred years so it was just like so
like it was like so obvious so and this
is why Barack Obama is elected because
he was the most anti-george W bush thing
that people could think of right and
then Obama comes in and continues all of
the Bush policies after running on I'm
going to repeal all of these policies
and then and look there was a pivot it
was right or it was in 2012. okay it was
when Obama was running for re-election
and what did Obama come out and say for
his re-election campaign did he come out
and say hey look remember I told you I
would close Guantanamo Bay and I did it
no he couldn't say that did he say I
ended the war in Iraq no he couldn't say
that did he say we're not torturing
people anymore did you say we're not
dropping No in fact by this point in
2012 not only had Obama continued the
war in Iraq and Afghanistan he had also
launched a stupid regime change war in
Libya he was starting to fund a civil
war in Syria and he uh well he had the
Drone bomb campaigns in Yemen and
Pakistan so what did he say he's got
this base of liberals who he hasn't done
anything that he promised so what did he
say I'm for gay marriage
I'm the first president who's ever been
for gay marriage and then put the White
House up with the pride flag colors and
if you go look at that look this was
this was a concerted effort from the top
you can go look there are these Nexus
charts where you can map out words in
major Publications I'm not talking about
Mom and Pop
news outlets I'm talking about the New
York Times The Washington Post like the
big dogs go track how many times the
word racism was mentioned and around
2012 it shoots up yep social justice
shoots up transgenderism shoots up White
Privilege shoots up this was forced on
the American people why are we having
these conversations now the people did
not wake up one day and decide we want
to have a national conversation about
chicks with dicks that didn't happen
this wasn't an organic movement it was
all of the most powerful people decided
this is what we're going to talk about
and why was that because it's the
perfect look when you're failing on
policy you pivot to a culture War you
pit people against each other so they're
fighting each other we had in this
country we had an Occupy Wall Street
movement where leftists were standing
outside of big Banks screaming we are
the 99 right Wingers had a populist
movement called the Tea Party where they
were outraged about the bailouts of big
Banks unsustainable debt government
spend egg they don't like that that's
not what the powers that be like you're
getting too close look they like you
fighting about issues like abortion now
I'm not saying abortion isn't a very
important issue it's a very important
issue but us fighting about that issue
doesn't scare anyone at the Federal
Reserve it doesn't scare anyone in the
CIA they don't care if you fight about
that issue they love you fighting over
transgender bathrooms they have no and
you can see this every day they're
stoking this culture War because they
have to to distract from the fact that
they completely failed on everything
else that everything in the 20th century
so far for America politically speaking
has been a disaster it's distracted
people with a submarine they distract
you with the submarines they love
stories like that CNN loves an airplane
crashing they love something where it'll
get clicks and no powerful people will
be upset about it if they actually loved
real stories that just got clicks
there's a lot of stories that get
clicked they've been passing them up for
years it's part of the reason why shows
like this shows by like Joe Rogan are
taken off because they can run stories
hey do you think that like people get
vaccine injured is not a story that
would generate a lot of views for CNN
the vaccine that the government just
mandated has hurt all of these people
that's a huge story why won't they run
it
because other commercials are freaking
pharmaceutical companies they don't want
to piss off powerful interests so
they're not in the game of that so they
have to create something for you to be
afraid of you know white supremacist
terrorism is everywhere you know we
talked about the tyrants big Pharma oh
yeah we talk about this on podcasts all
the time all right but there's two
countries listen I'm still on that that
was amazing that was it makes some noise
for a day man I was unbelievable on what
was it said thank you you know
I want to go to the next story I want to
go to the next story I I will tell you
guys the last rant what it did confirm
that the biggest threat to America is no
longer chicks with dicks that was very
important to know that thank you
you didn't let me finish the rants it
gets there
next one I want to talk about what's
going on in Hollywood anybody following
what's going on in Hollywood with the
strikes are you are you who has no clue
what's going on in Hollywood with
strikes okay this is pretty big uh Ron
Perlman who played Hellboy he played in
Hellboy and what's the other one he was
and he uh he was in Beauty and the Beast
back in 1987 he was the Beast and then
the other character was who uh bran what
was it Sons of Anarchy Sons of Anarchy
okay so Ron Perlman makes a video and he
calls out this man that's making 27
million dollars a year right now guys in
Hollywood it's absolute shambles May 11
500 people right from the writer's guilt
went on strike which means rap if you
you want to go on Google YouTube right
now 11 500 writers went on strike in May
the last time Jimmy Fallon has done an
episode was in May the last time Stephen
Colbert did an episode was in May the
last time Jimmy Kimmel did an episode
was in May because there is no writer so
go on YouTube and go to Jimmy Jimmy
Fallon's episode it's the best of it's
the best of it's the best of two months
no shows right no movies no shows no
streaming nothing everybody's on
lockdown then this week July 14 150
000 members from sag went on strike so
now there's a 160
1 500 people in Hollywood who are not
working and by the way if you're part of
Sac you can't have another job so for
example we were inviting Rob who were we
inviting here that said you can't James
Woods James Wood said I can't work I'm
part of sex so he can't even come on the
podcast to speak because that's
considered James's Camp emailed Rob back
saying I can because I'm part of sex so
watch this while this is going on
Hollywood has got all these issues Ron
Perlman and others respond but his one
is the most entertaining one uh brace
for impact there's a lot of curse words
but he's talking about somebody and I'll
highlight to you who he's talking about
go ahead
thing before I get office
the [__]
who said we're going to keep this thing
going until people start losing their
houses and their Apartments
listen to me [__]
there's a lot of ways to lose your house
some of his financial some of this Karma
and some of it is just figuring out who
the [__] said that
and we know who said that
and where he [__] lives
there's a lot of ways to lose your house
you wish that other people
you wish the family starve
while you're making 27 [__] million
dollars a year for creating nothing
be careful [__] be really
careful
because that's the kind of [__] to stir
[__] up
peace up
obviously he held back from you know
really Shona's emotions which was very
Noble of him definitely so we're sitting
there figuring out who this 27 million
dollar guy he's talking about so type in
I go online I'm like I'm thinking he's
talking about this guy we Google Kelly
we're in the room it's me you and who
Brandon right we're in the room uh was
Maverick in there more it was Mike in
the room one of the guys Mike was
Maverick was in the room Bambi yes so we
Google check this out
Bob iger's income last year type in Bob
Iger made 27 million dollars last
oh wow so he's calling out bye-bye look
at that so then Bob Baker had an
interview with CNBC that we go and find
we're not going to play it for you
because it's three four minutes long I
just kind of paraphrased what he said he
says look it's a shame what they're
doing right now because there's a lot of
people that are relying for jobs and
they got to go out there and do this and
they got to go out there and do that and
these guys have they have to live in
their homes have to pay their rents they
have to pay their mortgages so he's
talking about Bob Iger the CEO of Disney
making 27 million years so now
question that becomes okay so where do
they go from here with everything that's
going on in Hollywood watch some of the
stats on what's going on in Hollywood by
the way
we sat there it's me the group and I
said you know what I want to know let's
look at box office numbers if you can
pull up Bach Hollywood box office
numbers statista was it statistical peel
research statista Hollywood box office
World box office numbers uh statista
right there click on that one it should
be 2019 should be 43 billion no go to
the other chart that actually well you
can use that one zoom in a little bit
zoom in a little bit zoom in no this is
not the one it's another one Brandon if
you can text Rob when he finds it go
back uh maybe go to the second one that
could be the one yeah go to that one
right there I think this is the one
Perfect Look at night look at the 2005
Global box office go up so people can
see what the top Tyler says Global box
office revenue from 2005 to 2021. in
2005 Global box office was 23.1 billion
in 2019 it's 42.3 billion every year
it's going up boom covet happens drops
to 11.8 then it goes to 21.3 and last
year was only 25 billion dollars just so
you guys know we haven't gone back to 42
billion dollars yet fine no problem now
watch the other the other part we're
having this conversation
the discussion becomes you know Kelly
says Pat how do you feel about this you
know how do you feel about this I said
I'll never forget
uh the gentleman that was buying the
company Tom you'll remember this call
he says Patrick we have agreed on this
number he and I talk on the phone he
says the next three to six months
there's only going to be one Community
that's going to ruin this from becoming
a reality and it's the lawyers
your lawyers my lawyers are going to
fight and they're going to make this
deal not happen every time it gets to
the point when the deal doesn't happen
you want to get on the phone to get us
and no problem so you know who's lower
screwed it up first Tom whose lawyer was
it you can say it it's our lawyer our
lawyer day one on a zoom with all their
lawyers blasts all of them
you guys don't know what the [__] are
you doing so I get the call Pat you
won't even believe we were on December
was the most uncomfortable Zoom our
lawyer did this so okay I'll give him a
week maybe he's going to cool off he had
a bad day second day same thing third
thing fourth anyways eventually we have
to get on the call because this Deal's
not going to happen
Union in the middle right now is what's
ruining Hollywood Union in the middle is
getting these guys to do what they're
doing the guys at the top of all these
big companies are making the money
unions holding hostage because they're
asking for lots and well what about this
and what about that one part of the side
that the talent does have a proper
argument because this is you know
they're scanning actors right now and
once they're scanning your uh your body
they can use it without giving you
credit the end of the movie Flash have
you guys seen a movie Flash with your
kids the end of the movie Flash they're
using Dead characters and they have it
in there through CGI but they're not
paying that person
so essentially these guys are saying
wait a minute you're using my likeness
my body I should get paid some are
saying 100 I can see the debate being
maybe they pay you 10 they pay you 20
maybe they pay you 30 but it can't be
free it's me you can't do that pay me
Mike so there's good arguments there but
at the same time AI well we don't want
you to use a all this other stuff then
we wrapped it up with this and I want to
get your thoughts on this
I said let's go and measure the top 100
greatest movies of all time
what is the most credible source to go
to give me the website that we can trust
what is it IMDb perfect we went to IMDb
do you know the top 100 greatest movies
of all time
what decade had the most most uh movies
as a top 100 greatest movies
80s or 90s I think it was 50s was first
huh I want to say six was it 60s first
no I was
yeah so I think I think it was 50 60 70s
then it went to 30s 40s and then it was
tied with the 90s 1080s and then in 2000
was only three movies in the top 100 the
three movies were The Pianist if you've
seen it if you haven't it's a phenomenal
movie then it was Gladiator and I think
the other one was Lord of the Rings that
was from 2000. do you know in the last
20 years 23 years with all the
technology with all the CGI with all the
Photoshop all the stuff that they have
they've only produced three movies that
are in the top 100 greatest movies of
all time why well I think there might be
a direct relation between that because
sometimes you know when you go and watch
these old movies when they had none of
that what you needed to have was a great
movie story you know because you had to
have a great story because otherwise
it's like there's nothing else to do
with it yes whereas now you can really
just like it becomes a crutch just crazy
action scenes and crazy things like that
that aren't you know might be enough to
get people to go see the movie but
aren't enough for them to be like oh
this was like an all-time great it's
also look this whole industry has been
like what we were talking about like the
industry in in uh how people consume
news but how people consume
entertainment I mean we're in the middle
of a revolution nothing short of a
revolution like when I was a kid it was
very normal when I was a kid to not have
cable
um like when I was a little kid we were
kind of broke we didn't have cable we
didn't have cable until my mom met my
stepfather and he had cable and I was
like there's more channels what do you
mean but like we had uh
funnels on our TV it was like there were
five channels and then there was like
movie theaters and that was like
entertainment that was like the only way
to get something today like me and my
wife like I really we've turned on cable
maybe five times in the last year I
don't even know why I pay for it uh we
we're always like watching something on
Netflix or on Hulu or on Amazon or
something like that but we now have not
only do you for entertainment you not
only have you have a world of podcasts
and internet shows and all types of like
Services content creators all types of
streaming shows and then you also have
access to the entirety of Hollywood
all of the of the history of it right on
your what would be considered movie
theater size TV that you have several of
in your house surround sound so yeah and
like all I mean it's basically almost a
movie experience in most people's living
rooms today so they're they're just
tough when you hit something like 2020
where all of a sudden nothing's being uh
produced anymore and everybody realizes
all of these other options even once
things kind of reopen up back in 2021
it's like you're left with this like
well I don't really know if I need to
make sure I go catch the latest movie
on Netflix yeah Amazon Prime or which I
personally for me like I got two little
kids it's a whole thing for us to go out
to the movies you know what I mean if
there's a movie We want to watch I kind
of much rather find it in the house
anyway like and then we go out and do
something else it's just I think we're
in a revolution in this by the way it
nowadays we're so busy we're watching
movies on 2.0 it's kind of like Titanic
everything's fast but here's a decades
you guys want to know if you can put
this up so people can see it I don't
know if you guys can see it or not uh so
the number one decade was the 50s wow
then it went to 70s tights uh 60s and
90s were tied then 40s 30s then 1980s
and the last place is 2000s for movies I
literally only go to the movies when pbd
does a valuetainment field trip when we
go see uh air what was the last one air
right I saw air or I saw the sound of
Freedom thank you Matt zappala for that
recommendation but I also think that
like I don't even know what's in the
movie theaters these days but it's like
Fast and Furious 57 or Harry Potter 19
or Avengers 417 I think it's just the
same nonsense over and over and over and
over again but by the way did you watch
the last fashion the Furious movie no
have you watched Dave the last one I
don't think I I don't think I've ever
seen a full Fast and Furious movie the
new character they have
interesting individual so you're the guy
watching the movie there it is yeah
that's why I asked you if you watched it
so let's talk about sounds of Freedom so
by the way a big part of what's going on
as well when you think about all of this
is the ESG requirements which you have
to add in the movies you're forcing
people into these movies you have to
have a certain amount of number of
people part of lgbtq you know right now
in Hollywood to be nominated for Oscars
you have to have a certain amount of
disabled people working on a movie
yep you guys haven't it's cool did you
hear what I just said or no yes okay can
you please pull up the new guidelines to
be nominated for Oscars to show
everybody what the guidelines are you
have to be
did you did you actually hear what I
just said you gotta have a gay you gotta
have a [__] you gotta have a trans you
gotta have a black guy that turned into
a [__] that wasn't formerly gay like
there's so much d-e-i-e-sc can there
just be like can there be one person who
fits all of the like one just like one
black gay trans [__]
can you pull up the guideline here's the
guideline just so you guys if you wanted
to know so moving forward a at least one
lead actor significant supporting actor
has to be from underrepresented racial
ethnic group or specific country or
territory production that may include a
rap go a little bit to the right because
Adam's foot is not let me go the other
way the other way what's the other way
there you go it's Latina that may
include African-American black African
Caribbean descent East Asian uh Hispanic
Latino indigenous people Middle Eastern
North African Pacific Islander
everything except white men Jesus
we get it everyone else
and then by the way here's the other
part here's the other part here's the
other part watch this at least 30 of all
the app can you highlight that part I'm
reading at least 30 of all actors on
secondary and more minor roles are from
at least two underrepresented group
which may include women racial or I
think lgbtq and watch the last one
people with cognitive or physical
disabilities who are deaf or hard of
hearing
what
by the way the new guidelines hear me
out the new guidelines the last I think
50 movies that one movie there the Oscar
none of them would have won based on
these guidelines that's the direction
Hollywood is gone read A3 can you
continue with A3 go forward but what the
main storyline storyline subject the
main storyline theme or Narrative of the
film centered on underrepresented groups
women racial ethnics lgbtq people with
cognitive same exact thing as well but
by the way did you watch the last Fast
and Furious movie Pat I know which story
you're going to talk about the fact that
Aquaman was a guy that was gay yeah now
he's a he's a gay
guy in flambe
flam bumper like
like he was gay in the Fast and Furious
pretty much bro pretty much flamboyant
and doing his nails and doing the nails
of a dead guy and just just weird [__]
he was doing in the movie bro his
Aquaman gay or bisexual by the way in
about a couple minutes we're going to go
to anybody have any questions during
to questions on any questions you guys
want to have speakers shout out to the
Rocks uh little cousin right here by the
way let's wrap it up with this let's
wrap it up with this sounds of Freedom
yes okay Simple Story
told the story 100 million dollars
crowdfunded Christian movie sound of
Freedom hits 100 million dollars Taps
Mission Impossible Wednesday star called
strong new Moses on Fox
amen
[Applause]
I'm assuming you guys saw it I know you
did can you tell us what you're I mean
Matt you and I watch it together in
Bahamas Ricky have you seen it already
or not yes Matt your biggest takeaway
yeah I watch a movie we came back from
Bahamas and then uh on Tuesday in
Oakbrook we had a uh super bom and then
the next morning on Wednesday morning 11
30 on first show before I left on my
flight Oprah my smart Moon showed up to
the theater we packed it
um I can't
imagine being that father in that movie
who felt so daggone helpless
knowing that he didn't know who to call
who to talk to
and and he couldn't he can't track his
kids he's poor because they have the
resources
his babies just got taken he's a single
father I was resonating with that
because I was a single father raising my
kids
and I'm asking myself this question too
as well you know we all laugh about that
movie Taken I mean that's people think
it's an action movie what said movie
really it's a human trafficking movie
yeah but we missed it because we got
distracted with an action movie
I have a set of special skills I'm gonna
find you right so I'll ask myself this
question because you always you know
you've always uh coached Us Peabody to
always prepare for no matter what you
know if a distraction is coming away do
you have a action plan for that so I'm
asking myself this question who do I
call
if my kids are Amber alerted and
kidnapped
that has a special set of freaking
skills to go after somebody like this
and um
and we found them
and we had them on our you know we have
a podcast and we interviewed him
Wednesday and it was talking about a
case study that we're going right now in
Dallas right down the street from Frisco
is Louisville this 17 year old starts a
working case they're working right now
it's a 17 year old she's currently being
trafficked since she was 13.
she can't get out the life because of
him so you don't want to do this you
don't want to do this they take a selfie
in front of their mom's house
we know your mom lives and if you if you
don't do this we're also going to take
your 10 year old sister we're going to
bring him to the life we're gonna flip
her
so she does the job she's like can't do
this more I can't do this fine if you
don't want to do this morning you need
to recruit your replacement so in the
movie sound of Freedom the recruiters
weren't the guys it wasn't some weird
dude in the mask glasses and a white van
it was a woman
it was an unthreatening person
so this 17 year old girl recruits his 10
year old
and was horrified what happened
so she promises this girl candy in ice
cream
but what she finds is a bunch of guys
that kidnapped her
shattered full of Fentanyl and she had
to hear this 10 year old girl for the
next two hours gang raped to continue
the process of desensitizing her for the
rest of her life is going to look like
so Christian Muslim Mormon no matter
what left right can we all agree that we
never everyone have that happen to our
kids
that's our enemy
that's our enemy we're all distracted
all this [__] but the enemy is what
the drug trade is not even sexual to the
gangbangers
that
right now is not
the opportunity if you're a gangster
because it's expensive to get a drug
game would you buy a key for 30k and you
flip it for 60 right where are you sure
you do it or or how do you know these
numbers man I'm Chicago I watch
Ricky validate those jokes
yeah
but if if you got to get a key so you
can you can be your you know Corner boy
you can drug you in your city
but it's also expensive so for example
if you have crime and you're doing
drive-bys people know but they see a car
and you have a description they're going
to find you you have drugs people are in
drugs obviously you know by the way how
many guys were raised around people that
you saw in the neighborhood people on
drugs right hi it's crazy right how they
look so you can tell there's drugs in
the neighborhood the thing with human
trafficking you can't tell yeah
it's a hidden crime and if you got
caught with drugs you got caught doing
drive-bys you're going to get arrested
you're gonna be prosecuted you're going
to spend some time in jail the problem
with human trafficking is even if the
person gets caught with the person that
they're pimping out
because they have them in such a lock
they're going to deny that that's their
pimp because if they if they follow
through with it they know where Mama
lives they know where the family is so
say now that is my friend and what
happens is there's not enough laws
there's not the whole defund the police
movement guess what they've defunded
human trafficking they didn't learn
forces so we've had these non-profit
organizations to be the ones that are
that are taken guys Navy Seals if you're
a Navy SEAL a former law enforcement
special ops there's organizations that
are trying to recruit you right now to
be that Liam Neeson character to go out
and defend us because that is going to
be our next wave like we like to load
Jack when kids we are our cars are
getting ripped off right now imagine
having to get a LoJack for your kids
so that's the era that we're facing
right now and anybody that's against
this that's minimizing this that's
coming against this thank you for
exposing yourself we now know where our
enemy is
so by the way number one that's a man
right there that's a father right there
shout out to Matthew
emotions so seriously Pat recommended we
watch the movie right and I think you
watch it in the Bahamas I was on
vacation I don't know where I was and
then I get home and I see you do a video
with like 20 like an army behind you and
you're encouraging everybody yo go watch
this movie I go watch the movie and the
day before on the podcast we were
discussing it and there was headlines
Rolling Stone certain magazines articles
like disparaging the movie and basically
marginalizing the whole concept of the
movie for sure so I go into the movie
unbelievable already knowing all right
they called it a q Anon conspiracy
theory so I'm thinking all right let's
look for these Clues so I sit through
the two and a half hour movie and I'm
thinking all right like
when's the Q Anon thing coming
when's the right-wing conspiracy thing
coming and it was just generally a movie
about freaking child sex trafficking
period end of story and the fact that
it's politicized and there's people
being like no it's kind of okay it's
like so shocking to me well it's like
even if it's even if the argument is
that like it if they're saying like oh
it's they're making it out like this
happens in larger numbers than it does
it's like well if it happens at all
right that's the problem isn't that
worth making a movie about like you guys
make movies about things that are
incredibly rare all the time Dave it's
not that if it happens at all it
actually is happening more and more and
more and more so it's not just a tiny
little blip on the radar right there no
I'm just making the point that even if
it was it would still be legitimate to
actually raise awareness act and people
that are basically trying to minimize it
and marginalize it I don't understand
why well clearly I think obviously the
reason why it plays into this kind of
bigger uh political by the way I have
not seen the movie yet so I can't uh
comment on it although I'm I'm
definitely going to but clearly it's
like there's something to this idea of
like the evil of preying on children and
the evil of like sexualizing children
that is something that's on everybody's
mind right now and then here's an
example of like the most egregious form
of that and then you see it's it's very
bizarre to see these kind of like
um Progressive types
try who are kind of already have been
caught kind of normalizing the
sexualization of children
um but look there is I was talking about
this just the other day uh there was
that quote um by um what's the uh what's
the beautiful woman's uh name Levine uh
Levin the military uh yes the the
transgender in the middle of a picture
she was making the argument very very
blatantly beautiful woman with a penis
gorgeous uh she was making the argument
that like kids can uh kids can choose
yeah this former rear Admiral gentlemen
this is your health this is what
Democrats voted for as your health
expert this is a Navy Admiral
health expert well uh overweight man
that looks that this is a overweight man
this is a woman
she was a point so so yeah so this dude
was talking about um Dave how dare you
I'm sorry sorry so so it was a comment
about how um that kids uh you know um
that pubescent children should be
allowed to make the decision to uh get
hormone treatment and puberty blockers
because they know what puberty they're
supposed to go through and they know
this and look it it is obviously just
the idea of giving kids puberty blockers
or hormone is like horrific but there's
something almost more fundamental uh to
the foundational claim there which is
essentially that children can consent
because if you can consent to this
I mean you that that is the most
permanent life that is so much greater
of a decision than having sex or having
a tattoo or getting drunk you're talking
about permanent lifelong decisions
you need to be 21 to drink but you can
be 10 years old and cut your dick this
isn't the worst part about it there's
already a state that passed that if
parents don't affirm this [__] when
their kids are minors they could they
could take your kids from you I don't
know when that was proposed by the way
California they just luckily they just
vetoed it but uh because of one party
them that that has all the power in
California they just vote uh that uh uh
beat a pedophile or or sells uh having
sex with the minor or or sex trafficking
for minors is not of uh considered a bad
crime they literally just voted for that
and they got so much backlash that they
had to switch it over but it just
happened SB something in California they
literally just passed that so I'm saying
like there is something to fight off and
there
I hope people realize you know Tucker
Carlson gave up you know he gave that
speech it was the last speech right
before he got fired from Fox and started
the Twitter show and he had a point in
there that I thought was really really
profound where he was just saying that
like this isn't really a political
battle like this is a theological battle
when you get into terms like like the
idea that like pray you shouldn't prey
on children is not a right-wing view
it's not a left-wing view no yeah you
know what I mean this is normal no this
is view this is a good versus evil yeah
like and there's really no other way to
spiritual battle that other than that
Ephesians 6 11. that's it that's right
so then if it's not political then why
is it political well the political
process is being used but the point I'm
making when I say it's not political is
that it's not as if like if you get into
a if the the idea is if if you propose
that um taxing wealthy people and
redistributing that money makes for a
more just society and then I want to
argue well no actually in fact lowering
taxes allows those wealthy people to
invest in companies creating more jobs
and expanding the economy we're having a
political debate if you say I think we
should be preying on your children and
propagandizing them I'm not having a
political debate
because they're using the power of
government yes I mean there's just
there's no more like it's just the realm
is now in like a it's a theological
debate you're talking about child
sacrifice now this is not like it's just
it's a different uh type of debate it's
political because obviously laws and
politicians are involved in it I'm just
saying that it's like you almost have to
conceive of it in a different way this
isn't left wing versus right wing like
we have these different political
ideologies that I disagree with each
other it's a moral I disagree
I disagree there's not political one
that is not left versus right 100 it is
and it just is and I don't I don't care
what anybody says it's the truth because
there's only one party pushing it that
you communicate your children then
you're gonna get arrested if you don't
affirm their their gender that that all
this the SB [__] there's only one
party pushing it it is 100 political and
it's easily identified on who's pushing
it it's that simple no it is
one political party who's more guilty of
it what I'm arguing is like when you say
the term left wing like historically
what left-wing versus right wing has
meant is that left Wingers uh believed
in egalitarianism and right-wingers
believed in um traditional hierarchies
this doesn't fall into that like this is
a completely different thing that's what
makes it this is a different Beast Dave
that's what makes him more sick yeah no
I know I don't actually think we're
disagreeing that's even no no I know
we're not disagreeing that's what I'm
saying well your tone seems
let me tell you what but let me tell you
why the fact the fact that it shouldn't
be politicized you're my best friend bro
all right no let
here's a Bud Light
the fact the fact the fact that that the
fact that it's like it shouldn't be
political but it's for example where's
uh Natalia Natalia uh is sitting right
here her her mom post go watch sounds of
freedom and some goddamn idiot that
looks educated you can look at your
mom's Facebook thread I don't know if
you saw it already I'm going back and
forth with this guy he's like oh it's
some Q Anon conspirate right-wing
conspiracy Bro [__] you bro like what
are you talking about I agree like what
are you talking about and I guarantee
you if I look at his voting card it's
gonna have a big ass D on it
can I ask you guys because I haven't
seen I have not seen the movie so I'm
just generally curious is there anything
in it about how like there is something
like going on with the political classes
there's no so there's just this is zero
there's no like consistency
it's a hundred percent there's zero
politics and let me tell you what zero
let me tell you why I get more upset
about it okay here's what all of our
cultures have something going on
obviously yours went through a whole
like the Holocaust everybody's here
here's a reality Behind these right now
okay right now 30 of women
foreign
of my people coming up the Border are
being raped and human traffic coming
from the border of Guatemala to Mexico
to the Border
I've sat down in front of graffiti I
recruited this girl she when she was 15
she was gang raped by 12 men and the
only reason that she was saved was
because the lady that was cooking for
the men bought her from there to save
them I've seen this [__] it's not
right-wing or left wing and there's only
one goddamn party trying to make this
okay
and it's not okay it is not no you can't
mutilate your goddamn kids no you should
not lower the law to make it less worse
for these idiots to go to jail it's
defined who's supporting this much my
brother
you're right
I understand you're right to be outraged
it's appalling what's happening to girls
and boys on on uh coming up uh but it
happens to my country brother I
understand my country
the open borders policies or the de
facto open borders policies that you're
talking about of the Biden
Administration they were absolutely
pushed by the entire Republican
administrator the entire Republican
establishment as well Jeb Bush was out
there on the debate stage saying it's an
act of love we have to let them all in
here it wasn't until Donald Trump that
Republicans were even raising this issue
so I'm just saying it's just not there's
a lot of guilty
I I get it because obviously the only
reason illegal immigration works is
because it's illegal because you can
exploit I get that both sides profit
from that but there's when we have this
remain in Mexico but again I understand
what you're saying and I totally and I
don't disagree with you everything
you're saying are facts but we're living
in right now okay right now when you
have open borders and it incentivizes
people to traffic other people if minor
majority of the people that are being
affected by it are my people right now
not 400 years ago not your goddamn
ancestors right now yeah I agree in many
ways right now under this Administration
for for people that voted on this
President and it's happening on a local
level on a state level on a community
level right now yeah and that's my issue
in many ways we have the worst of all
worlds because it's it's like these de
facto open borders where to your point
it is still technically illegal so
you're still technically in this black
market where you're not protected by
anything so it's not just open borders
because they're exploited open borders
would be legal for everyone to come in
and that would carry with it alive one
last story I got one last story before
we wrap up it's it's guys if there's one
thing everybody here can do they can
talk okay we can talk for hours and
hours and hours I got one last story we
get a uh a breaking news video that gets
sent to us okay we have to talk to our
lawyers before we released it the
valuetainment broke this video just
earlier today a couple hours ago before
we did we texted we emailed uh General
McChrystal because it's General
McChrystal in the video uh talking about
North stream pipeline okay and what
happened to it North stream pipeline a
lot of people are saying well it was you
know Ukraine did it no it was Russians
that are putting it know who did it who
now General Crystal to be fair this is
not a regular person he's not a sergeant
he's not a captain he's a Four Star
General I've interviewed him seven years
ago we had a very good conversation
together and so we emailed him to let
him know do you have any comments on it
I don't believe we got to respond back
from him we'll play the clip and I know
you've spoken about this a lot I want to
get your reaction on this so here is
General McChrystal and a gentleman in DC
got this footage in DC
sends this video over to us if you can
play this clip there's no obvious better
solution in Russia I think Putin ought
to go but there's nobody that I'm aware
of standing on the wings
do you see like there's a lot more
radical people
in the beginning of that I was like oh
yeah Russia did it do you think what do
you think did that my son was that is
the leader of the energy teams at DIA
defense
[Music]
I mean there are people who benefited
from it and that was people who produced
natural gas so if you really want to get
conspiracies the United States made more
money off that deal anybody else there's
no benefits right but yeah but that's
you know because we were huge
beneficiaries we changed our policy we
started providing liquid natural gas
you know overseas and you know there's
no I don't know if you guys realize what
he just said a four-star general my
interpretation I want to get yours Dave
interpretation America was behind
possibly North stream pipeline coming
from a four-star general who worked
under Obama by the way just so everybody
knows so I'm going to give it up to you
if you want to give a little bit of
context behind the story yeah well if
people don't know General McChrystal was
he was in charge of the war in
Afghanistan uh under Barack Obama and he
he was the head guy like uh before
Petraeus took it over that this was his
War
um and um they're um or after betrayals
took it over anyway he was he was the
guy they had a falling out he was the
guy who got interviewed in that Rolling
Stone uh piece and he got drunk uh with
the the reporter and started just like
trashing Obama
and then he published all of it and then
he had to resign because like you're
really not supposed to do that when
you're a four-star general talking about
your commander-in-chief which is kind of
an interesting insight into how some of
the top military brass actually look at
the president there's obviously a lot of
evidence When Donald Trump was President
too that a lot of these people don't
really feel like they work for the
commander-in-chief which is disturbing
in its own way but what he's talking
about here is the north stream pipelines
I assume most of you guys know what this
is It's a natural gas pipeline that was
built from Russia to Germany
um and it was blown up
um late last year
it obvious they tried to blame it on
Russia it made absolutely no sense that
that this was Russia Germany had
basically agreed uh in part of the
western effort to support Ukraine that
they wouldn't uh use the pipeline but so
Putin blowing it up is just blowing up
his own pipeline he can close it from
his end there'd be no benefit to him but
there's an enormous benefit to Ukraine
and the West because the big fear was
that it was going into winter Germany's
having a lot of energy problems because
they've embraced these insane climate
change policies and so they were worried
that the Germans might break in the
winter and agree to start getting some
of this natural gas from Putin again if
they're dependent on him for natural gas
how much resolve are they going to have
to keep supporting this war with Ukraine
so it's not just the issues that he's
talking about that okay this also
benefits all these other oil companies
look who had the means mode of an
opportunity to do this
it's pretty obvious who it is there was
also uh um uh Sal Hirsch who had a great
uh bit of reporting on this that it was
absolutely America who uh blew up the
Nordstrom pipeline just to be clear if
that's true this is
um an act of industrial terrorism
against a NATO Ally who we're sworn to
you know defend if they're if they're
attacked
um and it just it I hope it at least
opens people's eyes up to like it's not
so clear like look I love America I just
hate our government so just to be clear
on that I just hate politicians
um that they are not the good guys in
this conflict it's not as simple and
Wars are never as simple as like Russia
bad Ukraine good America good Europe
good for helping them there's a lot more
to this conflict than that good guys
don't uh you know uh commit
environmental terrorism to one of their
closest allies and the truth this is
what I've been talking about for a long
time but if you if you look into the
history of this whole conflict Vladimir
Putin is actually absolutely wrong for
invading the war is illegal and it's
horrible and a lot of people are dying
um but Vladimir Putin was absolutely
provoked for decades by the West who
after winning the Cold War were the
sorest of winners and just did nothing
but try to degrade and humiliate and
poke and prod the Russians if there was
a long plan uh largely driven by
neoconservatives
um you can go read about it in their
project for a New American Century back
in the 90s where their attitude was
basically like instead of what even a
lot of the great cold Warriors like
George Cannon who was the founder of the
containment strategy who was fighting
the Soviet Union his idea was once the
Soviet Union fell was like oh this is
wonderful you guys aren't Communists
anymore you overthrew your Communists
now you can have freedom now we can all
be friends and the neoconservatives went
no now they're weak now is when we take
over the world and they used to they
used to draw the line in down the middle
of Germany okay and West Germany was was
with the West and East Germany was with
the Soviet Bloc and that was how Europe
was split and now we've expanded NATO
all the way up to Russia's borders NATO
is now taking over the entire and close
you know and they might you know from
what the The Establishment people will
say is they'll go what this is just a
defensive no a defensive Alliance NATO
no and they are a defensive Alliance you
know except for all of the times that
they fight aggressive Wars if you
overlook that stuff like Putin's Army is
only defensive except for when it
invades Iraq uh Ukraine um and so
basically in in 2008 it was announced
that uh Ukraine would be joining NATO
this is what really sent us all down
this path this has been Putin's Red Line
forever that you can't go any further
because your enemy as your neighbor yeah
they're a very strategic look yes
Putin's perspective NATO is not a
defensive Alliance right NATO is the
European arm of the American Military
Empire and from his perspective he's
like I cannot have you this is taking
over Ukraine there's just too many vital
strategic interests here I can't have a
um all this Hardware uh military
hardware on right on my Border in 1962
when the Soviets put nuclear weapons
into Cuba Jack Kennedy said that is
unacceptable it is an act of War for you
to have nukes this close to us and I
will blow up the world that was
literally what he said I will blow up
the world if you don't move these nukes
and then they got on the phone behind
closed doors and they negotiated and
they pulled the Soviets pulled their new
exact back and we pulled some nukes back
in Europe and we saved the world and the
fact that we haven't been from day one
of this conflict saying okay let's
negotiate what the deal is here okay how
about we pull our NATO uh Hardware back
a little bit and Putin you pull your
military back a little bit and instead
the Biden administration's policy has
been we will fund this war till the end
of time yeah like why why is that in
America's interest it's not no others
must be ruled by Kiev not Moscow by the
way many of you really passionately care
about that well Mike or Mike Pence is
not of his concern listen man as far as
I'm concerned and Ron DeSantis was a
heroic Governor during covet and he took
on the world and he did a very good job
for you guys but he's just nowhere near
good enough on this issue he's just
waffling on it whenever he's talked
about oh the problem is the mission is
ill-defined the problem is that we're
involved at all Trump has been
phenomenal when he's talking about this
issue Vivek Rama Swami has been
phenomenal and RFK has just been
unbelievable on this issue it's a proxy
war of choice on the border of the
country with the largest nuclear
stockpile in the history of the world I
I couldn't think of a more insane
Reckless policy for zero strategic
advantage and all it's doing is
continuing the dying yeah I just don't
think we need NATO anymore what was NATO
created for because NATO was created
because all the European armies or
countries were decimated through World
War II and NATO was created so there for
America and Russia doesn't come you know
come to Oregon to basically those are
the last big boys of the military these
countries now are rich is countries now
are making money far richer than Russia
they can defend themselves right and on
top of that every time we go because you
know every time I was deployed we're
always looking at News why are we why
are you going here why are we going here
who's fighting why are we fighting for
this because we're commanded to do so
and so when we're looking at this why
don't we just take care of our backyard
let's take care of our home there's so
much here our kids are at stake right
now that's you know the the Border
there's so many issues here we got to
take care of them I think America needs
to be selfish right now just like
obviously go in business you want to
help your family you want to help your
mom and dad you want to help the
community but guess we I got help first
yourself yourself you got to build a big
base shop you got to build a business
you gotta go field training right oh man
America needs to take care of itself get
rid of there we don't need any more that
these countries fight their own words we
are at the tail end of the podcast Make
some noise for all the folks here hey
Matt Ricky Adam thank you everybody if
you're listening to this
and you're with us before we wrap up
we'll be with you guys here in a minute
but I know the ladies there's a place
over there called the bathroom so you
guys want to run too but thank you for
your respect of sticking around uh for
those of you guys that want to be here
at the next live one we have vivec
ramaswana here in two weeks doing a town
hall right here in two weeks
if you haven't yet bought your tickets
text award a podcast to
310-340-1132 we'll send you the link or
go to
5990live.com Rob let's put that in the
comment section 59.90 live and.com get
your tickets we'll see you at this next
live event take care everybody bye-bye